NEW YEAR WITH SUB ONE AND AS
ALWAYS I FIND THE WORK THAT WE
DO IN SOMEONE TO BE BOTH
IMPORTANT INSPIRING AND
COMPELLING AND THEREFORE I'M
HAPPY TO BE BACK WITH ALL OF
YOU AND THE BUSINESS OF OUR NEW
YEAR. WE DO HAVE A VERY BUSY
YEAR AHEAD WITH APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN HEARING SCHEDULED
BETWEEN BOTH ON MONDAYS AND
HUMAN SERVICES ON. I ALWAYS
WELCOME AND COURAGE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION OTHER HEARINGS
AND HOPE HOPE THAT BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ALWAYS FIND SOMEONE TO BE
WELCOMING ACCESSIBLE.
RESPECTFUL TO ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED. AS YOU KNOW COMPARED
TO THE OTHER BUNCH SO BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES SOMEONE PROBABLY
HAS THE LARGEST WORKLOAD IN
TERMS OF BOTH STAKEHOLDER AND
UBER BUDGET PROPOSALS. AND IN
ORDER TO BETTER MANAGE THIS
WORKLOAD AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
GET TO A FINAL BUDGET. THAT IS
TRUE AND A FAIR REFLECTION OF
THE ASSEMBLY IS PRIORITIES WE
HAVE UT IN PLACE A NEW PROCESS
FOR SUBMITTING STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS. AS YOU MAY BE AWARE
TODAY IS THE DEADLINE FOR SUB
ONE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS. ALL
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF
BY CLOSE OF BUSINESS TODAY WITH
THE SUPPORT OF AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAMPION IN ORDER TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR HEARING THE
APPROPRIATE HEARING DATE. GET
EVERYONE'S SINCE WE IMPORT THIS
NEW. FOR OUR SOMEONE MAYBE
TODAY WE ARE STARTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THEIR NEW
DIRECTOR DOCTOR ON HEALTH.
OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON IS THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR SONYA ANGEL
I'M DIRECTOR AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT ON THE STATE OF THE
SOUTH IN CALIFORNIA AND- AN
UPDATE ON NOVEL CORONAVIRUS.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MISSION. WE AT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITES AND WHEN WE SPEAK
ABOUT HEALTH IS NOT JUST THE
ABSENCE OF DISEASE OR INJURY AS
A WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
DEFINES IT HEALTH IS ALSO AN
OVERALL STATE OF PHYSICAL. MAY
AND SOCIAL WELL BEING. AS SUCH
DETAINMENT POPULATIONS OPTIMAL
HEALTH IS AN ACHIEVEMENT THAT
ESTABLISHES A SOCIETY'S
CAPACITY FOR X. EXCESS. INDEED
GOOD HEALTH IS THE PRODUCT OF
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES AND
HEALTH ITSELF CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES HEALTH IS A
CORNERSTONE FOR SUCCESS AT
SCHOOL WORK HOME AND FOR LIFE
IN GENERAL. BUT BEFORE I LAUNCH
INTO THE OVERALL HEALTH OF OUR
STATE LET ME FIRST ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT I KNOW HAS BEEN IN
THE FRONT FOREFRONT OF MANY OF
OUR MINDS OF LATE AND AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR ACTIVITIES
HERE AT THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. NOVEL CORONAVIRUS
ALSO CALLED CODE NINETEEN. TO
START SOME BACKGROUND IN
NUMBERS. IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
THERE HAVE BEEN A TOTAL OF
FORTY THREE CONFIRMED POSITIVE
CASES. TWENTY FOUR WERE FIRM
REPATRIATION FLIGHTS. THESE
WERE FLIGHTS IN OPERATIONS
ORGANIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BRINGING HOME FELLOW
AMERICANS FROM CHINA WHERE THE
OUTBREAK FIRST DEVELOPED AND
TOOK AN EARLY STRONGHOLD. THE
OTHER NINETEEN CONFIRMED CASES
IN NON REPATRIATED PEOPLE
INCLUDE TEN THAT ARE TRAVEL
RELATED AND FOUR CASES OF
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD NO KNOWN
SOURCE OF EXPOSURE. FIVE CASES
WERE FROM PERSON TO PERSON
SPREAD FOR HIM THE SOURCES OF
EXPOSURE OR NOW. WE'RE TAKING
ACTION TOGETHER WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS THERE BEEN TEAMS IN
THE FIELD DOING CONTACT TRACING
WE'RE IDENTIFYING PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN EXPOSED IN
THESE POSITIVE TO THESE
POSITIVE CASES ISOLATING THOSE
WHO HAVE HIGHER RISK FOR
DEVELOPING DISEASE AND TESTING
THOSE WITH SYMPTOMS. CALIFORNIA
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED
IN ENSURING OUR RESIDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE REMAIN SAFE
AND PROTECTED. WE WERE PREPARED
FOR THESE CASES AND WHILE THEY
WERE CERTAINLY NOT WELCOMED
THEY WERE NOT UNEXPECTED. AND
WE'VE BEEN PLANNING FOR THE
POTENTIAL FOR GLOBAL SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE FOR OVER A
DECADE OUR EMERGENCY PLANS HAVE
BEEN CONTINUOUSLY UPDATED AND
REFINED BASES UPON BASED UPON
LESSONS LEARNED EXAMPLE FOR H.
ONE AND ONE IN A BOWL OF VIRUS.
IN THIS OUTBREAK WERE
CONTINUOUSLY UPDATING OUR
APPROACH AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE VIRUS AND TRACK IT SPREAD.
WE'RE EXPANDING OUR TESTING
ACTIVITIES INCREASING OUR
STATE'S LABORATORY CAPACITY
PLANNING FOR INCREASED DEMANDS
ON OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM AND USING
THE LATEST HEALTH TO MODEL AND
FORECAST THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. WELL WE'RE
REASSESSING THE SITUATION DALY
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
RISK TO THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S GENERAL POPULATION
FOR KOBE NINETEEN REMAINS LOW.
IF OUR RISK ASSESSMENT CHANGES
WILL MAKE YOU AWARE IMMEDIATELY.
IT'S NATURAL TO BE CONCERNED AT
A TIME LIKE THIS THIS IS A NEW
VIRUS BUT WE'RE LEARNING MORE
EVERYDAY AND USING THAT
EVIDENCE TO INFORM ACTION.
THERE'S LOTS OF GOOD
INFORMATION OUT THERE BUT
THERE'S ALSO SOME INFORMATION
THAT ISN'T QUITE RIGHT AND BACK
TO FEAR AND STIGMA. I KNOW THAT
ALL OF YOU IN POSITIONS AS
LEGISLATORS A TRUSTED MEMBER IN
YOUR COMMUNITY ARE RECEIVING
QUESTIONS. TO SUPPORT YOUR
NEEDS FOR RAPID INFORMATION
WE'VE BEEN PLEASED TO HOST.
REGULAR CALLS FOR YOU AND YOUR
STAFF. SEES ME AND WE ARE
FREQUENTLY UPDATING OUR WEBSITE
AT C. P. H. DOT CA DOT GOV OUR
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND THE
CDC'S ARE EXCELLENT RESOURCES
TO HELP DISPEL MISINFORMATION
THAT MAY BE CIRCULATING AND TO
HELP KEEP YOU UP TO DATE ON THE
LATEST INFORMATION. HOW HOW
CHEN THANK YOU. EVERY SAID SURE.
THANK YOU. OKAY SO WHILE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE IS IN THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR MINDS. HISTORY
SHOWS THAT AS US- THAN IN OUR
STATE AND AROUND THE WORLD SOME
OF THEM THE OUR GREATEST PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRESS HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN MADE IN THIS ARENA IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR THE
LEGENDARY JOHN SNOW TRACE THE
DEADLY KURALT. A CHOLERA
OUTBREAK PUMP IN LONDON AND
SHUTTING IT OFF STOP THE
OUTBREAK IN ITS TRACKS.
CONSIDER THE FOUNDER OF MODERN
DAY EPIDEMIOLOGY HIS UPSTREAM
APPROACH TO PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES GUIDED BY AN
UNDERSTANDING OF PRESENCE OF A
DISEASE OR HEALTH IN A
POPULATION IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
OUR MODERN DAY PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH. INTERSTATE ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES WERE A LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH. OVER THE LAST HUNDRED
YEARS SCIENCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTION IS CONTRIBUTED TO
PRODUCING BUT OVER HALF THE
OVERALL RATE OF DEATHS FOR ALL
GROUP. LIFE EXPECTANCY IN IS
BUT IT'S A HIGH PULL IT'S EVER
BEEN SEVEN NINE POINT FIVE
BERMAN AND EIGHTY FOUR POINT
FOUR FOR WOMEN. INFECTIOUS
DISEASES NO LONGER TAKE THE
MOST LIVES CHRONIC CONDITIONS
INSTEAD DO RESPONSIBLE FOR NINE
OF TEN DEATHS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. STILL THERE HAVE
BEEN MAJOR ADVANCES IN
ADDRESSING THE LEADING CAUSES
OF EARLY DEATH BOTH RATES OF
ISCHEMIC HEART DISEASE AND LUNG
CANCER HAVE DECREASED STEADILY
AND SUBSTANTIALLY OVER RECENT
YEARS. ADDRESSING HEALTH AND
THESE IS NOT ONLY CENTRAL TO
APPROVING POPULATION HEALTH
IT'S ESSENTIAL. GOOD HEALTH IS
NOT EXPERIENCE EVENLY ACROSS
OUR STATE SOME POPULATIONS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RATES
OF EARLY DEATH DUE TO
PREVENTABLE CONDITIONS. ANY
DISPARITIES OR DIFFERENCES IN.
OUTCOMES EXIST BETWEEN
POPULATION GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHEN THOSE DIFFERENCES ARE
DUE TO STRUCTURAL OR SYSTEMIC
DIFFERENCE THAT. DIFFERENCES
THAT UNJUSTLY AFFECT SELECT
POPULATIONS THERE CALLED HEALTH
INEQUITIES. RACE ETHNICITY
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN SEX GENDER
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AGE
GEOGRAPHY ARE ALL EXAMPLES OF
CHARACTERISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH
INEQUITIES. FOR EXAMPLE MANY
HEALTH CONDITIONS A CURRENT
HIGHER FRQUENCY AND EARLIER
AND WITH GREATER SEVERITY AMONG
POPULATIONS OF COLOR AND THOSE
EXPERIENCING DOES YOUR
ECONOMICS. LOWER SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS. AND THE CONDITIONS THAT
PRODUCE THESE CONDITIONS
DIFFERENCES ARE STE SOCIAL
STRUCTURED THEY'RE CALLED
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
PRETTY AND RACISM ARE TWO OF
THOSE CONDITIONS. ONE STRIKING
EXAMPLE IS WHEN COMPARING THE
HEALTH OUTCOMES AMONG BLACK AND
WHITE POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE AGE ADJUSTED
ALL CAUSE DEATH RATIO IS 30%
HIGHER FOR BLACKS THAN WHITES
THESE DIFFERENCES. BECOME EVEN
PRINT IN U. STAGES. DE. RATES
FOR TWO AGES FIVE TO FOR ARE
TIME HIRAM BLACK THAN WHITES
AND FOR CHILDREN A ZERO TO FOUR
THERE TO POINTS TO TIMES HOW.
THE GOOD NEWS THAT FROM OF THE
LEADING CAUSE OF IN THIS. WE
KNOW WHAT TO DO. WE KNOW WE CAN
PREVENT MOST LONG CANCERS BY
STOPPING SMOKING WE KNOW WE CAN
PREVENT EARLY HEART ATTACKS AND
STROKES BY CONTROLLING BLOOD
PRESSURE AND LOWERING
CHOLESTEROL. AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE INTERVENTIONS ARE NEEDED TO
DO THAT. AND IF WE DO THIS WITH
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO HEALTH
INEQUITIES WE CAN CLOSE THOSE
GAPS AND OUTCOMES. WHILE MOST
OF OUR REPORTED DATA CONSIDERS
HEALTH BY EXAMINING ILLNESS IN
A POPULATION OUR COMMUNITIES
ALSO HAVE GREAT ASSETS AND
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE ALL OF
THESE CAN BE INVESTED IN.
SUPPORTED AND BUILD UP. THE
COMMUNITIES CAN LEAD CREATING
HEALTH THROUGH SOLUTIONS THEY
KNOW. WILL HELP THE PART SINCE
OUR FOR. INACTION ONE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MOST UNIQUE IN THE SENSE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS IS
POPULATION SURVEILLANCE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH USES OUR TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AND DATA ANALYSIS
LABORATORY TESTING AND
SCIENTIFIC PRACTICE TO IDENTIFY
THE MONITOR HEALTH ISSUES THAT
OF THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
PRACTITIONER EXPERTS AT
IDENTIFYING BUT AN
UNDERSTANDING ROUTE BECAUSE THE
AND UNDERSTANDING SECTIONS
ACROSS ILLNESS ISSUES. PUBLIC
HELP ALSO CONDUCTS
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF
COMMUNITY AND POLICY LANDSCAPE
TO LOOK AHEAD TO THE NEEDS OF
POPULATIONS IN AN INTENSELY
CHANGING ENVIRONMENT WE
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES USING A HEALTH
EQUITY LINE WORRY OUR FOREIGN
DATA COMMUNITY EVENTS
EVALUATION. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DIDN'T DEVELOP AND PURSUE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES AND TO
WORK WITH OUR MANY PARTNERS TO
PROTECT AND IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OF ALL PEOPLE. HEALTH IS THE
PRODUCT OF ONE'S CUMULATIVE
EXPERIENCE ACROSS THE LIFESPAN
ONE IMPORTANT INTERSECTION IS
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH. IN
THE END IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
LIVING LONGER BUT LIVING WELL.
HEALTH AND WELL BEING ARE.
SHAPE BY COMMUNITY. PLACE
MATTERS I OFTEN HEAR PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO MAKE HEALTHY CHOICES. BUT
YOU CAN'T EAT HEALTHY CHOICES
IF YOU DON'T HAVE HEALTHY
CHOICES. AS A PHYSICIAN I KNOW
THAT WHILE I CAN TELL MY
PATIENTS TO EAT MORE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES IN MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS. NOT BE GROCERY
STORES BY. VEGETABLE ARE
EXPENSE. FOR THOSE ON A LIMITED
BUDGET THE CHOICE OF EATING
MORE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
MIGHT MEAN NOT AND MEDICATIONS.
SO WHICH IS THE HEALTHIEST
CHOICE. BY SIMPLY MAPPING WE
KNOW THE SOCIO ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND COMMUNITY
ASSETS BOTH INFLUENCE HEALTH
CHOICE. HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND
THE VERY BY GEOGRAPHY AND
INTERACT IN COMPLICATED WAYS.
TEAMING UP PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL SYSTEM RESOURCES CAN BE
SYNERGISTIC WAYS TO MAKE OUR
ASSETS GO FURTHER MANY KEY
IMPROVEMENTS IN POPULATION
HEALTH OF BEEN ACHIEVED THIS
WAY DECREASES IN HEART DISEASE
AND LUNG CANCER AS WELL AS
OTHER NOT WORTH THE REDUCTIONS
IN. ANY CONDITION CONTACT
STRUCK THE PUBLIC DISEASE
HEPATITIS C. HEPATITIS B. AND
H. I. V. HAVE ALL THE FLUID BY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND CLINICAL
ITEMS WORKING TOGETHER. UNLESS
PROCESS I'VE SPENT A- DE IN
YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE. BY HIGHLY.
INJURY RELATED CONDITIONS
INCLUDING DRUG ASSOCIATES TO
DEATH ROAD INJURIES SUICIDE AND
HOMICIDE. YES IN THE AGING
POPULATION ARE DOMINATED BY
CHRONIC DISEASES INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND CANCER.
THERE IS MUCH WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT HEALTHY AGING NOW AND
EVERYONE BUT OUR BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSURE HEALTHY
AGING IS START WHEN PEOPLE ARE
YOUNG. THE IMPACT OF CHILDHOOD
AND UNITY ADVERSITY TOXIC
STRESSING CUMULATIVE TRAUMA IS
A ROOT CAUSE OF SOME OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING CALIFORNIA.
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD THE GOOD
EXPERIENCES ACES CAN HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES THROUGH THE THROUGHOUT
ADULTHOOD AND LEAVE PEOPLE MORE
VULNERABLE TO ENVIRONMENTS AND
BEHAVIORS THAT CAN LOOT LATER
FOR HEALTH. IN CAL FOR SIX
THREE. PERCENT OF. ADULT ZING
ONE. IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH CAPACITY THIS
INCLUDES CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ADDRESS LEADING RISK FACTORS
ANIBAL DEATHS LIKE TOBACCO AND
HYPERTENSION STOPPING VAPING IN
HOUSTON RE IN TEXAS DISEASE
CONTROL THROUGH VACCINATION
EDUCATION OUTREACH WILL BE
ESSENTIAL WE WILL USE OUR WITH
THE BALL WE WILL ALSO MAINTAIN
EDEMA IMMOBILIZING. WOULD HELP
IS USED CORRUPTS TO Y. FIRST
LOOK SEVERAL DO CHALLENGING CAL
WERE HEALTH STAND ASIDE BECAUSE
WE HAVE USE BY SO TO LOSE DOING.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT I
LOOK FORWARD TO JOIN YOU IN THE
FUTURE TO DISCUSS THE DETAILS
OF THESE DEVELOPING PLANS. FOR
ALL THESE AREAS AND MORE WILL
BE EXPLORING WAYS TO STRENGTHEN
OUR SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS TO
ENSURE THEY ARE NOT LEAVING
ANYONE BEHIND BECAUSE WHILE WE
MEASURE WHAT MATTERS WHAT WE
DON'T MEASURE ALSO MATTERS
THERE ARE KEY POPULATIONS WHICH
OUR CURRENT STANDARD POPULOUS.
IS DO NOT CAPTION I'LL- AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE ARE NOW KEEP.
SOME BECAUSE THE SURVEYS
THEMSELVES AREN'T DESIGNED IN A
WAY THAT WOULD ENGAGE IN FULLY
THE UNDOCUMENTED RURAL
COMMUNITIES LGBT Q. PERSONS
JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATIONS
AND PEOPLE EXT. HOMELESSNESS
JUST A FEW OF THE EXAMPLE. WELL
WE'RE TAKING STEPS TO ADDRESS
THOSE GAPS IMPROVING OUR
DATASETS SYSTEMS WILL REFLECT
ALL POPULATIONS TO REFLECT ALL
POPULATIONS IS A PRIORITY
WITHOUT THAT UNDERSTANDING THE
DESIGN AND REFINEMENT OF OUR
INTERVENTIONS TO SEMIS. THE
FULLY REAR. TODAY THROUGH MY
FIRST. HELP AT LARGE I PROVIDED
A BROAD OVERVIEW OF WHAT OUR
DATA IS TELLING US WE'RE LIVING
LONGER AND MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS STILL UNACCEPTABLE AND
I'M JUST INEQUITIES EXIST
PROMISING IS THAT FROM WEST OF
THE CAR POOR HEALTH EARLY DEATH
WE KNOW WHAT TO. SOLUTION EXIST
OUR BUSINESS AND ONCE. BILLET
TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS UNDERSTAND
WHICH POPULATIONS ARE MORE
DEFECTIONS AFFECTED AND MEASURE
PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTATION. I
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE
AND- THE REST THIS HEARING WILL
BE FOCUSED ON FUNDING SOME OF
THOSE INTERVENTIONS WHICH CAN
SHE TRAJECTORY OF THE STATE'S
HEALTH. CLOSE BEG KNOWLEDGE
WHILE WEEK. THE STAND AND
DESCRIBED AS YOU CAN HELP IN
AGGREGATE EVERY DATAPOINT REPS
THAT REPRESENTS THE PERSON A
MOTHER A FATHER A CHILD A
PARENT A NEIGHBOR MAYBE EVEN
WHAT HAVE YOU. ARE CHARGED IN
PUBS IF LIFT. WELL BEING OF ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE TELL THE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IT'S AN HONOR FOR
ALL OF US TO BE A PART OF THAT
MISSION AND WE THINK VERY MUCH
TIME ALEX. WORK WITH YOU. AS
YOU PLEX PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU DOCTOR ANGEL AND I'M PLACE
OBVIOUSLY MATTERS BECAUSE I
WENT TO ON HELD JUST NATURALLY
AND COULDN'T. DIDN'T KNOW THE
EXACT PRONUNCIATION BUT LIKE
THAT WERE ABLE TO CORRECT US-
WE WILL TAKE A MOMENT TO. SEE
IF THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS- SOME WELL THEN WE
WILL START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. WE'LL JUST GO DOWN THE
LIST. IT'S AN DOCTOR ANGEL
CRACK. THAT'S PERFECT FOR THE
POSITION SO MOST OF THESE-
DEALING WITH THE CORONA VIRUS
AND WHAT'S GOING ON- DO WE HAVE.
CURRENT NUMBERS ON ABOUT WHAT
IS BEING SPENT BY YOUR
DEPARTMENT- AND PET
PREPARATIONS FOR A PANDEMIC.
THOSE ARE NUMBERS THAT WE CAN
GET AND PROVIDE FOR YOU I DON'T
HAVE THE WE ARE TRACKING THAT
YUCCA- QUESTION TO- GOVERNOR'S.
OR SNICKERS ADMINISTRATION AND
SPENT MONEY ON PREPARATIONS FOR
ADDRESSING- POTENTIAL EPIDEMICS
STOCKPILING- MASS PROTECTIVE
GEAR MEDICINES EXCEPT RUSSIA.
ARE WE TRACKING THAT- ALONG
WITH THE TO FIELD HOSPITALS
THAT THEY PUT IN PLACE AND IS
THERE BORN NEEDED. SO I CAN
TELL YOU WHAT WE'RE TRACKING
OKAY WE AGAIN IT'S BEEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN WHEN WE
PURCHASED MANY OF THOSE AND I
WAS ACTUALLY PART OF THE
PURCHASE. MOST OF THE THINGS
BACK AND I'M- DEPUTY OF OUR
POLICY AND PROGRAMS. I'M WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF EXPIRED MASKS
LIKE TWENTY MILLION. I WE DID
GET PERMISSION FROM BOTH- CDC
AND I ALSO TO USE THOSE MASKS
THEY'VE BEEN STORED UNDER
TEMPERATURE CONTROLLED WE'RE
GETTING GUIDING WE JUST GOT
THAT GUIDANCE FROM CDC. WE ARE
OF DURING GUIDANCE- HERE
TOMORROW FROM WITH ALONG WITH
CAL OSHA SO THAT WE CAN THOSE
IN. THIS OP. THE MOBILE ABOUT.
HOUSE REALLY AND I AM SUB. SOME
NOW SERVICE. I AN- LARGELY SHOW
PROPER AS WE YOU UNDER FIVE
FIRES BUT WE DON'T HAVE BEEN.
SO AND A- I ALONG WITH THE- ON
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN PUT OUT
INTO THE FIELDS OF MUTUAL AID
REGIONS. AND THERE IS ONE THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE THAT. FIRES
NOT CARD UP SO HOW FUNDS HELLO
IT HAS SOME OF THE MATERIALS.
WE ARE LOOKING YOU HAVE A- AND
PUT SOME OF VENTILATOR. JUST
OUT. HOSPITAL BUT THEY ARE
WROTE BEING THEM IN USING THEM
AND THAT. QUICK AND FORTY.
BUYER AT. BUT INSURANCE POLICY
BOUGHT IT FOR A BI FLU PLANNING
TEN FIFTEEN YEARS A AND NOW WE
ARE SORT OF LOOKING OUT RIGHT
NOW WE MIGHT NEED IN THE FUTURE
OF THE US. AND WERE COMPILING
THAT LIST AND WORKING WITH TGS
CARE WE HAVE ALSO FROM PUT IN
AN ORDER FOR THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW AND NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS BUT GIVEN THE
GLOBAL MARKET SHORTAGE WE DON'T
EXPECT TO CAP UNTIL APRIL OR
MAY. OKAY QUESTION THREE HAS
SPENDING FOR LARGE SCALE
PANDEMIC RESPONSES BEEN CUT
UNDER PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
I'M THE ONE PIECE THAT DID GET
CAUGHT PRETTY QUICKLY AFTER WAS
PUT IN PLACE AS WE HAD SIXTEEN
MILLION FOR LOCAL PANDEMIC
PLANNING NOT HUSBAND IT WAS
CAUGHT THE VERY NEXT YEAR I
CAN'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS TWO
THOUSAND SIX OR TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN IT WAS PUT IN PLACE IT'S
NOW DOWN TO FOUR NINE NINE. ON
THE- OKAY. QUESTION FOUR. WHAT
IS THE CURRENT CONDITION YOUR
ANSWER THIS OF THE TO FIELD
HOSPITALS- SO THAT ONCE COVERED.
IN ITS CURRENT CONFIGURATION
ARE THE MOBILE UNITS SET UP IN
A WAY THAT WOULD BE EFFECTIVE
IN ADDRESSING THE SITUATION SEE
SAID WE'RE BACK PILED AND GET
IN THEIR WATERS AND MORE OF
RIGHT NOW SET UP TO BE USED AS
SHELTERS ON THEY ARE AS
HOSPITALS WE ARE EXPLORING AS
ADMINISTRATION OTHER THINGS WE
COULD UE IF WE NEED TO EXPAND
HEALTH CARE. KING I HOPE THAT.
RECENTLY CLOSE TO OR- IN
BANKRUPTCY OR YOU KNOW THE
OTHER ONE THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE VERY QUICKLY AND BE
READY FOR THAT USE. NOW IS
THERE A THE AND TO SEE IT I'M
YOU SAID A LOT OF THE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES- WERE OUT OF STOCK. DO
WE HAVE ANY ANSWERS ON WHEN
THOSE THINGS ARE BEING RE STOCK
OR ONE WILL HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH CDC TO PRIORITIZE THE
HOSPITALS HAVE PAID IS OR WHO
HAVE SUSPECT. OR CONFIRM CASES.
AIRPORT TIES IN GETTING THEM
THOSE SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT
THERE'S ALSO OF AS YOU KNOW A
FEDERAL STOCK STOCKPILE THAT
COULD BE INVOKED IF WE NEED TO.
ON THEIR NOT YET BREAKING INTO
THE THINKING IT. GOT WORSE.
ACTING NOW SUB BUT WE ARE
WORKING. IT IS TO BE A
TEMPORARY SHE FOR. LIKE MOSCOW
GLOVE AND AYE PROTECTIVE GEAR
BUT WE ARE WATCHING THAT WERE
IN MENTORING OUR NEEDS WE ARE
IN MENTORING THE HOSPITAL'S ON
AND OUR LOCAL PARK. SEE WHAT I
HAVE ON HAND. TIMELINE OR
ANYTHING. THEY DON'T HAVE A
TIME LINE. PUSHING IT PART AS
WE CAN WE ARE- WORKING AT CDC
AND HHS BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
WE'VE HAD REPATRIATION WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BROUGHT
INTO OUR- SO THEY DO SO. SAYS I
ALREADY IN TERMS OF GOT IT.
NEXT QUESTION. WE NEED. A LARGE
SCALE MOBILE QWERTY FACILITIES.
I'M MORE ARE WE THERE YET- WE
GET THERE IS THAT SOMETHING SO
AS YOU KNOW QUARANTINE AND I'M
IN THE WORLD OF PUBLIC HEALTH
QUARANTINE HAPPENS BEFORE YOU
HAVE COMMITTEE EACH MISSION SO
WHAT YOU HAVE ME TRANSIT AND WE
MOVED TO MEDICATION AND THEN
OUR GOAL BECOMES. GOING THE
SPREAD AND SO CORPS ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE NEXT STOP
HOWEVER I AM I THINK WE ARE
STILL LOOKING AT THE NEED FOR
QUARANTINE AS WE TRY TO SLOW
THE SPREAD. OF THIS DISEASE AND
SO IF WE- VOTERS COMING AND
THAT WE KNOW HOW TO EXPOSURE WE
STILL WANT TO QUARANTINE THEM.
BUT THIS DOES NOT- GET BAKER.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TURNED OUT-
AND ARE MORE PEOPLE. THAT HAVE
ALREADY RETURNED DIVERT
TRAVELERS WHO ARE SELF DURING
THE- SENATE BOMB HOT. PUSHERS
AND ARE STILL BE TRAIN. VERY
BASIS FOR THEIR FOR DAY. PERIOD
I'M CAN DOWN THE DAYS TO COME
NOT ONCE THEY BECOME POSITIVE
OR THEY WILL NOT ALLOW THEM A
THE BASE OF THAT'S WHY WE WOULD
NEED A QUARANTINE FOR. CARE
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THE- OF ANY
NEW MORE FOR BONDS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP BETTER
PREPARE THIS. I'M IN THE I
THINKI'M THE BEST ONE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. OKAY. NOW
THEY REFUSE TO RESPOND IN
WRITING AND SO THAT'S WHY I'M
ASKING- LET'S SEE HERE. I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF OPTIONS AND
IN SOME WAYS HARDEN BUILDINGS
IF WE DIDN'T YOU KNOW OUR
EASIER AND WE NEED TO HAVE SORT
OF EVALUATE THAT AND ACROSS THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND WHAT WE
NEED. NOW AS FAR AS SMALLER
SCALE PREPARATION ASSISTING
LOCAL PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTIES BLICK AXIS STILL USE
WHICH PERSON PURCHASING NOT.
THE BASICALLY CANCER EXEDRA FOR
PROPER CLEANING AND SANITATION
EQUIPMENT WHAT ARE WE DOING IN
THAT FIELD SCHOOLS SCHOOLS AND
OTHER STUFF- WE ARE NOT
INVOLVED WITH THAT WE ARE
GIVING GUIDANCE WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING ALONG
WITH STEVIE BUT I THINK THAT'S
YEAH I'M THE OF EDUCATION AND.
DO YOU FEEL IN GENERAL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPERLY YEAR
RESOURCE TO HANDLE THIS
SITUATION BOTH CURRENTLY IN
LOOKING. FORWARD IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. I THINK
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW
AND THAT RIGHT NOW WE ARE NOT
SPARING IT WE ARE REDIRECTING
AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE NEED WE
HAVE GOTTEN PERMISSION FROM CDC
TO USE ANY BUT HEALTH SERVICE
OFF THEY FIND. AND WE ARE ALSO
ENDS ARE. HIRED THAN OTHERS
HELP WITH. AND SO. AS WE NEEDS
WE WILL RAISE THEM UP- WE'VE
BEEN TOLD TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO- AND SO I DON'T THINK
RESOURCES AND WILL WILL KEEP
YOUR HAIR IF WE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS IT'S
NICE THAT YOU CAME PREPARED AND
HAD SEVERAL QUESTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO ASK- I DO WANT TO FOCUS.
A LITTLE BIT ON IF I. GUARDING
RESOURCES AND- WE TALKED ABOUT.
THE GOAL HEALTH BUTWE SHOULD
ALSO TALK ABOUT FISCAL HEALTH.
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE
SO THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH THE-
ISSUES OF PANDEMICS AND LAST
YEAR WE PUT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND TO THE BUDGET HOW
ARE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS USE THE
FUNDS INTO. ARE WE CONCERNED
THOSE FUNDS HAVE OTHER.
PURPOSES AS WELL. SO WHAT I
THINK YOU KNOW JUST FROM A
GLOBAL WE THINK PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALWAYS
LARGELY ARE NOT FUNDED ENOUGH
AND THAT IS JUST SORT OF OUR
YOU KNOW I CAN'T TELL YOU
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE OR HOW I'M BUT WE KNOW
THAT IS PART OF US YOU KNOW OF
A PRIOR DISEASE ACROSS
GOVERNMENT'S LEVEL BUT I THINK
INTO THE FORTY MILLION I'M YES
THAT'S A- FULL TERMS OF. PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- WE- WILL NOT WORK
USE THOSE DOLLARS TO. THERE'S A
CROSS I'M AND I KNOW MICHELLE
GIVENS IS HERE FROM JACK AND
SHE CAN PROBABLY TELL YOU MORE
ABOUT HOW EXACTLY THOSE DOLLARS
ARE BEING TO YOU AND WE CAN
TELL YOU THAT AS WELL BUT I
THINK YOU MOVE THIS OF THIS AND
GET GET BIGGER CLEARLY THERE
WILL BE. IN ME I HAVE READ.
STATE PAUL. PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH NO DURING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE I'M AN CON RACE AND WE
ARE DIVERTING RESOURCES FROM
WHEREVER WE NEED AT BOTH THE
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL LEVEL
RIGHT NOW TO GET THE BEST
PEOPLE WORKING. IN THIS I'M A
LITTLE LIAM WHERE IN THIS FOR
DOCTOR ANGEL'S SAKE SINCE WE'VE
NEVER MET- BUT HAVING WORKED AS
A FIRST RESPONDER AS ANY OUR
DOCTOR I WAS ON THE FRONT LINES
WHEN WE HAD TWENTY. AND
FORTUNATELY I ACTUALLY. FLEW
HOME FOR MY WIFE AND KIDS WHICH
WAS. NOT THE NICEST THING I'VE
DONE- AND YET. TO THAT ONE
THERE ARE THESE TYPES OF PAN X.
IT IS USUALLY THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES WHO ARE ALSO
AFFECTED BY AND SO FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE WATCHING FROM HOME
AND WONDERING. REALLY ARE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE FRONT TO
EXPOSED TO MANY PEOPLE AND NOT
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC. AND
GENERAL THOSE MASKS AND UP IN
PEOPLE TO TOUCH THEIR FACE MORE
AND PASSING ON THE- ILLNESSES
RATHER OR CONTRACTING THE
ILLNESS RATHER THAN. GOING TO
PREVENTIVE. AS MUCH AS WE CAN
IT'S JUST. DOING WHAT WE'RE
ALWAYS SUPPOSED TO DO GET
ENOUGH SLEEP EAT WELL DRINK.
WASH OUR HANDS HIGHER TRAINING
APPS ARE THAT AND ALL OF OUR
MESSAGING AS WELL YEAH. I
WANTED TO SAY I APPRECIATED THE
STATE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE COULD HAVE. SOME
CONTINUED DIALOGUE REGARDING
SPECIFICS. AT THAT I'M ALWAYS
VERY INTERESTED IN THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AS WELL
AS THE HEALTH INEQUITIES THAT
WE SEE. HAVING COME FROM A PART
OF THE STATE WHERE WE FELT THAT.
TO OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS YOU
SPOKE ABOUT THE HUMAN BEINGS AT
THE END OF THIS I AM QUITE
AWARE OF WHAT WORK YOU DO IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE VOTE. THE
PEOPLE WHO STEP. WHEN IT COMES
TO BIG PANDEMICS LIKE COVERT
NINETEEN AND SO. APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK YOU AND YOUR OFFICE
ARE DOING. AND WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN BOND.
TO I'M IN DESCRIBE ISSUE TO FOR
YOU THE RESPONSE TO A PANDEMIC
OR WIDESPREAD OUTBREAK SUCH AS
THE CURRENT SITUATION WITH KOBE
NINETEEN. REALLY OVER A FIRE
AND ALL OF GOVERNMENT RESPONSE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD- RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE CD PH I'M SORRY AND
HELLO YES WORKING IN
COORDINATION TO ADDRESS VERY AT
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE
RESPONSE. FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND AGENCIES HEALTH AND
HUMAN SAVE SERVE EIGHT WERE. I
OF WE ARE LOOK WE'VE ARE
MEDICAL AND HEALTH CONSENTED TO
OUR NEIGHBOR. WILL COORDINATE
IN EVERY TREE AYE WE ARE
WORKING WITH RETURNING PERCENT
FOR THROUGH AIR SCREENING
LETTERING NOW IT. NEVER TOP.
FOR A DAY THE TESTING NOT A IN
OUR STATE HEALTH LAB BUT NINE
OTHER. PUBLIC HEALTH LABS AND
SOON MOST OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
CLUBS WILL BE ONLINE AND ABLE
TO TEST WE ARE DOING CONTACT
TRACING OF INDIVIDUALS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- REDUCE STE. AND WE ARE ALSO
IT AGAINST IN TECHNICAL ASSIST
TO HEALTHCARE FACILITIES TO THE
POP BACK TO OUR PARTNERS TERMS
OF. ACTION WELL HOW TO KEEP
YOUR FAMILY SAFE. IN A ROW OF
SETTINGS IN THE ANSWER. EATING
RESOURCE FOR PERSONAL TALKED OF
A QUOTE A THIS I AM SO IS OUR
PARTNER IN ACTIVE OF THE-
URGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER THEIR
ASSISTING WITH THE TRANSPORT OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM REPATRIATION
EFFORTS FROM THE AIRPORT
SCREENING TO THE MILITARY BASES
THERE I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
GUIDANCE TO FIRST RESPONDERS
AND THEY ARE ALSO COORDINATING
UP A LOCAL LEVEL WITH. LOCAL
EMS AGENTS AND LOOK AT OUR
SERVER COSTS FROM THAT END AS
WELL HELLO IT IS I ALSO WORKING
THERE BRING THE- COORDINATE A
RESPONSE NOT ONLY PUBLIC MATTER
ABOUT A ALL STATE AGENCIES
THERE HAVE A DAILY UNIFIED
COMMAND GROUP THAT MEETS THEY
ARE ON THEY'VE ESTABLISHED A
JOINT INFORMATION SOUND. CENTER
I'M STANDARDIZED MESSAGE- AND
THEY'RE ACTING SELECT OF IT
TAKE HOLDERS AND HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR IF WE HAVE ANY THAT THEY
WHAT MEET THE PIECES THE OF ALL
OF EMERGENCY. LETTER IN THE-
I'M STOP FOR A SECOND TO PUSH.
BUT WILL SAY I RECEIVE THE
EMAIL THE LAB. SEVERAL DAYS
FROM CALLOW YES AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT REGARDING THIS AND I
DO APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK.
ARAMBULA PRESENT. FRAZIER
MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
WOULD. IF WE CAN CONTINUE ON
ISSUED TO BRANDON AND I AM
SURE- BRAND IN UNISON THE CHIEF
DEPUTY FOR OPERATIONS ISSUE
NUMBER TWO AND ANOTHER WAS
GIVEN THE OVERVIEW OF OUR
DEPARTMENT BUDGET GOT IT SO TO
SUPPORT OUR DEPARTMENT
GRAHAM'S- WE ADMINISTER A
BUDGET A THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION- THAT'S REVISED TEAM
TWENTY AND THEN FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ARE PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS THREE
POINT TWO BILLION. THIS
INCLUDES SUPPORT HUNDREDS.
AREAS MO OF OUR BUDGET COMES TO
US IN THE FORM OF- SPECIAL
FUNDS ROUGHLY HALF OF OUR
DEPARTMENT AND OVER FIFTY
DIFFERENCE BY FUNDS WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT. ANOTHER ROUGHLY 44%
COMES US IN THE FORM OF FEDERAL
FUNDS AND THEN A SMALL
PERCENTAGE COMES TO US FROM
GENERAL FUND AND- POINT TO BILL.
TWO THIRDS OF THAT GOES OUT TO
SUPPORT LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT NEEDS- IN
TOTAL FOR YOU THIS YEAR AT
LEAST AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
POINT INTO WE HAVE TEN BE IT
WILL BE PRESENT TO YOU. TO OUR
ESTIMATES ARE ESTIMATES FOR
DRUG. PROGRAM ISN'T SCENES
CATION AND ARJUNA DISEASE
PROGRAM AND A LOT OF THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY WILL BE TOUCHING ON SIX
OF THOSE TODAY. A COUPLE
HIGHLIGHTS THAT I WOULD POINT
OUT TO YOU THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR- FOR
TWENTY. ONE WE HAVE INCREASE OF
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
LICENSING CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
THIS YEAR. MAY RECALL A LACK
BUDGET WE IMPLEMENTED A NEW
CONTRACT WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. PART OF THAT INCREASE
INVOLVES YOUR TO OF A THREE
YOUR FACE IS IN WHAT LA. FOR
THEM TO GET MORE RESOURCES TO
DO THE IN THAT COUNTY- AS WELL-AS SOME- FUNDING IN POSITIONS
OF FOR OUR STATE WORK THAT ARE.
NEW FOLKS DO WORK OUTSIDE OF LA
COUNTY. SO THERE'S AN INCREASE
THERE FOR THAT AS WELL AS
THERE'S- THE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND THIS YEAR- FOR A
CALIFORNIA COGNITIVE CARE
COORDINATION INITIATIVE- THESE
FUNDS ARE I'M GOING TO BE USED
TO ESTABLISH A COORDINATION
AND- IN INITIATIVE. THE HOUSE.
CENTER CANADA PROGRAM AS YOU
NOTED IN OUR AGENDA WE DID WE
DO HAVE A THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR- BUDGET AND GET
HAS HEARD IN NINETY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE OVER
OUR REVIEW IN THIS YEAR BUT I
WOULD POINT OUT THE LARGE
REPORT THAT ACTUALLY COME FROM
A NUMBER ONE TIME. TEAM TWENTY
FOUR. I THINK IT'S TEN TODAY IS
ACTUALLY GONNA GO INTO QUITE A
FEW OF THOSE BUT YOU MAY RECALL
THE FORTY MILLION FOR INSTANCE
THAT WE PUT IN PRESS CITY
PREVENTION TO THE COUNTY- A
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF. FOR GRANT
PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES WE Q.
WOMEN'S HEALTH DISPARITIES- AND
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION TO
ESTABLISH THIS- THE NETWORK FOR
SICKLE CELL DISEASE CENTERS THE
STATE SO GAME TOUCH MORE. AND
BUT THAT'S WHAT THE DRIVING I'M
OUR GENERAL WAS ONE TIME WE
ALSO CUSTOMER. OKAY SO MOTION
IN WHERE ARE WOMEN SINCE IN
CHILDREN CASELOAD I'M ABOUT IT
THE MILLION THAT CLIMATE OUR
FUNDS WELL AS OUR READ. THAT
SUPPORTS AYE PROGRAM. AND THEN
WE ALSO SAW SOME REDUCTIONS TO
OUR FIFTY PROP FIFTY SIX
IMPROPER NINETY NINE PER YOU TO
READ JUST MEANT THAT OCCURRED
IN THOSE FUNDS. BUT WE WILL OF
COURSE LIKE. HERE COME BACK TO
IT. IN WITH YOU NEW PROJECTS
ESTIMATES OF COULD CHANGE IT.
IN TIME. WHAT DOES THE MEASURE
THINGS THAT WERE. UP ANGEL THIS
YEAR WITH THAT LIKE I SAID WE
DO HAVE A NUMBER OF OUR PROGRAM
EXPERTS HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THE SPECIFIC.
GOALS THAT ARE IN OUR BUDGET.
THIS YEAR PANEL. AT AND GIVE
YOU SOME TIME TO CHAT WITH THEM
TOO. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THANK YOU WE WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE PROPOSALS
YOU MENTIONED WITH ISSUE THREE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ANGEL IN
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS I'M DANA MORE I AM THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH
STATISTICS AND INFORMATICS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY. CITY PH
REQUESTS TEN POSITIONS AND ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE HOLE STATISTICS BRUSH AND-
TWENTY TWELVE. THE ON GOING TO
INCREASE DEPARTMENT WIDE
ADVANCED ANALYTICS AND
PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISION MAKING
CONTINUING IMPLEMENTING MASTER
DATA MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES FOR
IMPROVED HEALTH INFORMATION
MANAGEMENT. IMPLEMENTATION OF
DATA DRIVEN COMMUNITY PENSIONS.
THE POSITIONS ARE EXISTING
POSITIONS FUNDED WITH LIMITED
TERM FEDERAL GRANT FUNDING THAT
IS SENDING. THIS REQUEST IS TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE POSITIONS
WITH STATE SPECIAL FUNDS. THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA
OKAY. NO COMMENT BRINGING IT UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE SEEING NONE
I WOULD AT THE- IN A GENDER-
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS GOING TO
REQUEST AND WANT SOME OF THESE.
POSITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO HELP US WITH THE
STATE OF THE STATE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SO THAT WE CAN DETERMINE
CERTAIN ANALYTICS TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK AND TREND AS WELL AND SO
WE JUST WANNA TO WORK WITH YOU
ROUTE IF THERE'S MORE SPECIFICS
YOU CAN PROVIDE AS PART OF THE
AGENDA LATER. AND THE SEARCH
RENDON YES WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AGAIN YEAH AND THAT'S IT WE
APPRECIATE FOR THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT PRESENTATION. DONE EACH
YEAR WE CAN LEARN MORE AND MORE
EACH ABLE TO KIND OF THE TERM
AND WHAT WILL. TO REPORT I
THINK THE THIS. AND CHEESY WILL
DEFINITELY UPS WHEN IT COMES
TO. THE DATA THAT WOULD BE MINE
TO BE THE KIND OF USE THAT. AND
WE LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
YOUR STATE. COME UP WITH HI AS
FAR AS THE- BURKE. I LOOK. AND
WORK WITH. AS FAR AS A MEET
YOUR NEEDS THE WAY FOREIGN SELF
WONDERFUL THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE HOLD ISSUE THREE OH IN THE
ON TO ISSUE.
FOR I HOPE. MY
NAME IS CONNIE MATCH ON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR FAMILY HEALTH YOU'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING OFFERS FROM WHERE
ONE OF OUR DIVISIONS AND THEN
THE ESTIMATE- REVIEW FOR A
GENETIC DISEASE SCREENING
PROGRAM. OUR THIRD DIVISION IS
MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH AND ON IN
YOUR- SUMMARY DOCUMENT I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT ON ON
FOURTEEN THAT THE FAMILY
PLANNING DIVISION. NOW IN THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
SO. THAT WOULD JUST WANT TO
POINT THAT OUT THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SO WILL TURN IT OVER TO
WAKE FIRST WHICH IS THE NEXT
ISSUE. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CHRIS
NELSON I'M CHIEF OF THE WEIGHT
DIVISION AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. IN FOR OUR WEEK
ESTIMATE THE WICK PROGRAM IS
FUNDED BY FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL
AS REBATE FUNDS FROM THE
CONTACTED INFANT FORMULA
MANUFACTURE. NO GENERAL FUNDS
AS PART OF THE WICK PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. WE DO HAVE
SUFFICIENT FEDERAL DOLLARS
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER EXPENDITURES
TO CONTINUE TO DECLINE DUE TO
DECLINING PARTICIPATION. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR THE ESTIMATE
INCLUDES NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
GRANT REVENUE. WHICH CONSISTS
OF SIX HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FROM THE FOOD
GRANT. AS WELL AS THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LOCALS SINCE AND STATE
OPERATIONS. WE ALSO HAVE ONE
pDOLLARS IN REBATES FUNDS WHICH
ARE USED FOR FOOD. FOR A TOTAL
OF JUST OVER ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. WICK MUST
SPEND REBATE DOLLARS BEFORE
ACCESSING ANY FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND SO ALL OF OUR REBATE FUNDS
ARE ALWAYS SPENT. A WE DO
ESTIMATE THAT WILL SPEND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FEDERAL GRANT.
AND WILL BE RETURNING SOME ON
FOOD ALLERGY. A WHICH THEN THEY
TURNED AROUND A REALITY TAKE
OFF FOR. THE FOLLOWING QUARTER
THE FOLLOWING YEAR. HERE THE
ESTIMATE ALSO IN SO MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND STATE OPERATIONS
DUE TO ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM U. S. T. A. FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE WORK. ACT
AND WILL ALSO ADDRESS GIVE AN
UPDATE ABOUT THE WORK PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND DRESS
DECLINING PARTICIPATION. SO
FIRST THE ROLL OUT OF THE NEW
COMPUTER SYSTEM KNOWN AS WITH
QUIET AND THE CALIFORNIA WITH
CARD AND YOU CALIFORNIA WITH
CAP IS GOING VERY WELL. WILL BE
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION BEFORE
FEDERAL DEADLINE OCTOBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. AND WESTIE A
PROJECT THAT THE WHAT REGION
WILL BE THE FIRST REACHED LIKE
BY THE THREE. AND WE'RE VERY
GLAD TO BE A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR
TO THAT OF THIS THE CURRENT
STATUS OF OUR ROLL OUT WE HAVE
COMPLETED EIGHT OF THE TEN
WAVES THAT INCLUDES SEVENTY ONE
OF OUR EIGHTY THREE LOCAL
AGENTS IS THIRD HUNDRED OF OUR
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED GROCERIES.
NEXT WE GO. WAVE NINE IS THE-
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY DOWN TO
FRESNO COUNTY AND THEY'RE
PREPARING VERY WELL AND THEN
MARCH THIRTIETH- WE GO LIVE
WITH WAVE TEN WHICH IS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SOME PARTS
OF SAN BERNADINE OKAY. AS WELL.
TO DATE SHE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND CARDS WITH
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOWNLOADS OF THE NEW CALIFORNIA
WITH OUT. WHEN WE BEGAN
IMPLEMENTATION ARE PROJECT
CONTRACTOR HAD A GOAL OF ABOUT
50% OF WHAT CARD OWNERS WITH
SOME OF THE AFTERWARD ABOUT 74%
SO WE'RE REALLY EXCITED THAT
FAMILIES ARE USING THAT. WE BY
THE POINT FIVE MILLION. EIGHT
SO WE'VE HAD REALLY A HANDFUL
OF CALLS ABOUT ISSUES WITH THE
CARD AND CONSIDERING TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION TRANSACTION WE'RE
REALLY REALLY PLEASED WITH HOW
WELL THINGS ARE GOING. FAMILIES
HAVE AN INCREDIBLY LEE POSITIVE
ABOUT THE ROLLOUT ABOUT USING
THE NEW CARD AND THE WAY OUT
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY PATIENT IN
THE LOCAL AGENCIES AS THOSE
LOCAL AGENCY STAFF GETTING YOU
TO THE NEW SYSTEM. STAY OF ROLE.
FAIRFIELD THAT ONE OF THE
SITES. AND OF PURCHASE OFFENSE
AT ME THAT I WANT TO GET HER
QUOTE RIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS IT
WAS RIDLEY REALLY NICE. OF SURE.
FLEXIBILITY AND SHOPPING WITH
THAT MADE POSSIBLE WITH THE
WHAT CARD WAS LIBERATING. AND
THE ABILITY TO SCAN FOODS YOU
OPT TO VERIFY THEIR AUTHORIZED
IN HER FOOD BOUNCE FORCED WENT
TO THE REGISTER. SHE SAID WAS
EMPOWERING. OF THE LOCAL
AGENCIES AND STORES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL DURING THE ROLL OUT
HAS BEEN A KEY PRIORITY FOR US
WE HAVE NUMEROUS CALLS WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES BEFORE THEY GET
READY TO GO ROLL OUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE READY. FELT
MANY CALLS FOR LOW. TO YOU
THERE'S WITH THEIR FAMILIES WE
SEND STAFF OUT TO EVERY SINGLE
SITE FOR EVERY SINGLE WAVE AND
FIRST FEW LAPS DAYS OF GOAL
WIFE SO WE'VE BEEN CRAP. THE
WHAT. SAN TV. NEEDLE BISHOP AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN OUR STAFF
VISIT GROCERY STORES IN THE
WEEKS PRIOR TO GO LIVE TO MAKE
SURE THE STORES ARE READY TO GO
OFTENTIMES THE STORE WILL
REPORT THEY ARE. TO GO OUT AND
TEST NOT IS READY MAY THE
THOUGHT. TO WORK THEM AND MAKES
THAT THEY ARE BE ABLE ABLE TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES ON THOSE GO
LIFE DAYS. THE EVA PROJECT
REALLY IT'S BEEN A HUGE
UNDERTAKING AND OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH IT OFFICE.
AS WELL AS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY AS LONG AS WELL
AS PROJECT CONTRACTORS AND OF
COURSE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
GROCERY STORE. HAS MADE THIS
PROJECT HUGE BASS. AND LASTLY
OF AN UPDATE ABOUT DECLINING
PARTICIPATION IN OUR RESPONSE
TO THAT. A WE'VE BEEN REPORTING
THAT THE PASION THE WHAT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN DECLINING
CALIFORNIAN NATIONALLY SINCE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
LAST LATEST DATA CAME FROM USDA
REPORTS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COVERAGE RATE IS 61% WHILE THE
NOW AVERAGES 50% SO WE'RE STILL.
FOR TO SEE. AND BALTIMORE
QUESTION PRESS BUT WE'RE DOING
WE'RE DOING BETTER THAN MOST
STATES BUT WE CAN ALWAYS
IMPROVE. ENERGY FOCUSED THREE
AREAS UNDERSTANDING REACHING
AND SURVEYING SO A COUPLE
EXAMPLES ABOUT WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING UNDERSTAND THE DATA A FOR
WE HAVE A DATA MATCH WITH MATT.
PROGRAM DONE THAT SHOT MATCH
TWICE ONCE LOOKING AT THE MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DATA AND SECOND
TIME LOOKING AT THE MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN DATA. AND THE
RESULTS ABOUT INFO OLDER BOTH
PROGRAM. AS WELL PROGRAM THE
OTHER WE DON'T LOOK PREGNANT
WOMEN. NO ONE ONE AS PREGNANT
SO WHERE. JUST IN SOME CHILDREN
IN THE STATE MATCH. THE MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RESULTS SHOWED
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND INFANTS AND CHILDREN
AND MEDI CAL THAT WE'RE NOT IN
WORK AND THE INITIAL REACTION.
GO OUT AND TRY TO REACH RECRUIT
THE- BUT WE KNOW THOUGH THE
WEIGHT COVERAGE RATES FOR
INFANTS IS VERY HIGH. LOOK
FURTHER INTO THE RESULTS AND WE
MANY OF THESE CHILDREN HAD BEEN
IN WORK IN THE PAST SO IT'S NOT
TO SIMPLY READ THE CHILDREN TO
TELL THEM ABOUT WHERE. WE THEY
ARE PARTY NOW ABOUT WHAT WE
NEED TO UNDER. THEY LEFT THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS PROGRAM. AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND INFANTS AND
CHILDREN THAT WERE MEDI CAL AND
WORKED. IT LOOKS LIKE THE SAME
NUMBER BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT YEARS WERE ABLE TO
SEE THE CHANGE. SO WE HAD PRO
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN A ONE
PROGRAM AND- IN BOTH THEY'RE
BOTH PROGRAMS AND- THE OTHER SO
WE'RE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND A LOT
MORE. AND WHY. FAMILY IS TO.
ONE PROGRAM THE OTHER. WE'VE
ALSO REACHED CONDUCTED A
STATEWIDE SURVEY IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FOUNDATION
ENTERPRISES WHICH IS OUR
LARGEST LARGEST WITH LOCAL
AGENCY IT WAS STATE WIDE SERVE.
ENGLISH MANAGED. INTO THE- WEEK
FAMILIES THAT HAD A CHILD AGE
ONE TO FOUR. MISS A MAJOR
FINDINGS IN THAT RESULTS OF
SURVEYS SHOW THAT FOOD AND
EDUCATION WERE EQUALLY MOST
IMPORTANT BENEFIT TO WORK SO
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO SEE
THAT THE EDUCATIONAL IS
IMPORTANT. AS WELL. PRUDENT
WILL KEY REASON IN THE FOOD Y.
FAMILY STAYING AWAKE BUT THE
BENEFIT THAT THEY RECEIVE HER
FOOD SOME VEGETABLES IS NOT
ENOUGH. ALSO ONE ON ONE IS THE
MOST COMMON THE PER FOR
PREFERRED METHOD OF NUTRITION
EDUCATION WE HAD ASSUMED THAT.
IT WOULD BE- MAYBE NOT THE
FIRST BUT SOMETHING MORE ONLINE
OR VIDEO WOULD BE THE TOP
CHOICE BUT ON ONE ON ONE WAS
THE TOP CHOICE. AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THAT- ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS ADDRESS- HAD
THE FAMILY CHANGE THE FEEDING
PRACTICE BECAUSE OF SOMETHING
THEY LEARNED AT WORK IN A
NATIONAL SURVEY SHOWED 60%
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY FIVE SO WE'RE
BY THAT WERE ABLE TO MAKE.
UNDER A REACH CATEGORY A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WERE WORKING ON
WE'RE WORKING WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE'S FOOD FOR LIFE
INITIATIVE TO DEVELOP A BROAD
SCALE TEXT MESSAGING CAMPAIGN
TO CONNECT THEIR FAMILIES TO
WORK. AND WE'RE ALSO DO OPENING
IMPROVE TEXT MESSAGING LANGUAGE
TO HELP IMPROVE INCREASE WITH
APPOINTMENT ATTENDANCE FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS PARTICULAR. THING
ON AFRICAN AMERICAN MOTHERS. I
SERVE UP. PART OF WE HAVE. FIVE
ALL OF THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
AND SIMILAR CURRENT INITIATIVES
INCLUDE TELL LACTATION OPSIN
OPTIONS FOR BREAST FEEDING
PROJECT PLANS TELL HEALTH FOR
OUR MIND YOUR APPOINTMENTS
DEVELOPMENT OF A FULL WIG CLICK
POLICY TARGETED HAS TO MY TO A
TEXTING FOR MESSAGE OF IT'S AN
ALL NEW TRISH TEXT MESSAGES.
ENHANCED PORTIS. ARMOR RETAIN
PRESENCE IN. AREAS AND OF
COURSE ROLLING OUT THE CARD AND
CAL WAKE. THANK YOU I WILL LOOK
TO SEE OF THE SUB COMMITTEE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS. IF NOT- I WILL
SIMPLY COMMENT THAT- HE WHERE
CAN THE CARD IN THE APPS ARE
GREAT WAYS FOR US TO HELP TO
STEM THE- DECLINING PARTICIPATE
IN THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
PROGRAMS. IT UP SHOULD ALLOW
FOR BETTER ACCESS TO ALLOW MORE
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM- DON'T MENTION WILSON
THIS COMMITTEE BUT- THERE'S
SENATOR AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER. ON
THE- THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR I'M JUST CURIOUS HAVE. IT
IS 61% ENROLLMENT OF ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE IS IT SAID THAT'S HIGH
THAT'S THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION OR OR- SECOND HIGHEST
EARLIER THIS THE HIVE MAY I AM
GONNA GUESS ABOUT SIXTY THREE
BUT JUST. DO YOU DESERVE FOLLOW
UP WITH FIND OUT WHY THEY'RE
NOT ENROLLING IN THE PROGRAM
YOU MISSION REACHING OUT TO
CHILDREN HARDLY IMAGINE YOU
REALLY REACH OUT TO CHILDREN.
OKAY THANK YOU MISS EMMA SURE
WHAT. CHRISTINE. BUT I'M
CURIOUS YOU KNOW WHAT IT YOU
KNOW WHAT IS I MEAN WE FEEL
THAT THERE'S STILL A TREMENDOUS
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO HAVE THE
COMPANY PURCHASED AND WITH THE
NEED AS THE PLAYERS. THE CARD
OBVIOUSLY IS GOING TO BE- BUT
WHAT WHAT OTHER IMPEDIMENTS ARE
THERE OR WHAT WHAT'S MISSING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. SO THERE HAVE
BEEN. HE'S ME THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF- RESEARCH STUDIES
NATIONALLY PARTICULARLY LOOKING
AT WHY DO PEOPLE LEAVE PROGRAM
THERE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY DO
PEOPLE DISCONTENT. THERE
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM SO
SOMETIMES IT'S A FAMILY THAT'S
ELIGIBLE DOESN'T AND ROLE AT
ALL BUT MORE THAN LIKELY IT'S
THEY HAVE COME TO THE PROGRAM
THEN STOP COMING. STILL THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS TO
ME THE WAY. PERHAPS IN HOW
FRAZIER SNAP. THERE MIGHT BE-
IF THERE IS MORE TIME THAT YOU
HAVE TO COME INTO THE OFFICE IT
YOU HAVE TO CHECK IN WITH WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NOT. THE CAN'T BUY
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT WITH THE
BENEFITS AND SO WE DO SEE THAT
SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS ABOUT
SHOPPING ARE COMING IN IF I GET
JENNIFER APPOINTMENTS. THING SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THINGS THAT
WERE. TO RE IS THOSE THE VERY.
THEIR NOT BE A WHOLE VARIETY OF
OTHER ISSUES UNFORTUNATELY NOT
EVERY. YEAR CUT ANSWER. WHY THE
PROGRAM. IN A LOT OF WORK THAT
WE- CALIFORNIA NASH. TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND ALL REASONS WHY
SOMEONE DOESN'T COME TO THE
PROGRAM AT. SO THERE ARE AS
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE SO THEIR
REQUIREMENTS SEARCH FOR CERTAIN
BITS THAT'S PART OF THE PROGRAM
IS A YES STATE REQUIREMENTS FOR
FEDERAL FEDERAL REQUIRE. THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS- THERE'S A
FOUR TIMES YEAR NUTRITION
EDUCATION CONTACT SO IT'S NOT
JUST THAT WE LOW BENEFITS ON
YOUR CARD AND THEN. OFF YOU GO
FOR IT. THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR OPEN IF
YOU WILL INDULGE ME I'D LIKE TO
MOVE TO ISSUE A LOT EIGHTEEN
FOR. EMBLEM. ZERO BOB.
I THANK
YOU MISTER TURN AT THE PLATE IF
IT PLEASES THE CHAIR WE LIKE TO
BE BRIEF. THANK YOU CUT OUT ALL
THE- POOR BUT NONE THE LESS WE
WANT TO PRESENT TO ESTABLISH
THE FIRST TRANS- TRANS GENDER
WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND AN
APPROPRIATE- FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I AM WE FELT.
THE IMPACT IN OUR DISTRICTS
CERTAINLY WHEN. WHEN I HEALTH
PROVIDERS OR AGENCIES- DON'T
KNOW HOW TO COMMUNICATE- THE
POPULATION. AND SOME OF THE
FUNDS WOULD GO TO MEDIC MEDICAL
CARE MENTAL CARE OR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING WE FEEL IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO SMALL. I ASK FOR
SUCH AN ISSUE OUTSIDE OF LIKE
TO PRESENT TO ARE CO PRESENTER
ALSO SPEAK ON THE ISSUE YOU YOU
MISTER REMEMBER. WELL HELLO.
MEMBER HAS SUPER GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE MY NAME IS MACHE I'M THE
MANAGER POLICY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE CHANCE LET
THE NOT COALITION WERE A
NATIONAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
AND A DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDER
TO TRANSIT. TO TRANSGENDER NON
CONFORMING. UNLESS ANGELES AND
ARGAN IS A SOUND LIKE MANY
TRANSIT ORGANIZATIONS- WERE
BUILT OUT OF NECESSITY TO FILL
A GAP OF SERVICES AND RESOURCES
THAT AREN'T ALWAYS PROVIDED TO
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE. BECAUSE
OFTEN A COMMUNITY IS LEFT OUT
OF CALM THE SANDS IN OUT OF
CONVERSATIONS IN SPACES LIKE
IS. A FOR. SHIN AND IN WHAT IT
WOULD BE AN INTENTIONAL
INVESTMENT IN THE LIVES OF
TRANS PEOPLE BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY VOTE ON HEALTH I'M
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT HEALTH IN
A HOLISTIC WAY SO THAT'S
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADDRESSING THE
BARRIERS. THAT FOLKS OFTEN FAYE
FACE WHEN TRYING TO ACCESS
MEDICAL CARE WHETHER THAT BE
OUT BUT DON'T KNOW HOW TO WORK
WITH THEM LIKE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AND DOCTOR IS- WHAT
THAT HE- IN TROUBLE TRYING TO
GET LETTER. FOR THEIR AND A
WIDE FOR OF THAT FOLKS FACE
WHEN I'M DEALING WITH THE CORE
TO. BUT BESIDE OUR MEDIC HEALTH
THERE IS OTHER FORMS OF. HEALTH
THAT IS THE PERIOD A AT THE
PERSON BECAUSE THERE SO MANY
BARRIERS. WHEN ACCESSING TO
DIFFERENT. ASPECTS OF. AND SO
FOR US WE WANT TO LOOK AT
INVESTING IN TRANSIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT AN PROVIDE
PROGRAMMING THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THAT HEALTH AND WELLNESS NEEDS
OF TRANS PEOPLE. AND SO THAT
YOU CAN INVEST IN THIS AND CAN
LEARN MORE ABOUT IT AS WE GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SOMEONE SANTIAGO.
SHAPE WOULD I THE SOME IF WE
HAVE ANY. SEEING NONE I WILL
COMMENT AND SAY I WORK WITH DR
BURNELL WHEN I WAS IN. AND SHE
WAS WONDERFUL SHE WAS- YOU
TRANSTAR- WHO WORKED IN THE
VALLEY AND IT WAS VERY RARE FOR
US TO. FIND SOMEONE WHO COULD
HELP CONNECT. AN IMPORTANT PART
OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND. SHE
ENDED UP WE- SHE IT HARD TO
PRAY. IN THE AND UP MOVING THIS
FROM. AND I LEFT A HUGE HOLE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR PEOPLE
HAVE SAFE AND UNDER. WHAT IT IS
YOURS TING AND SHE QUITE
TEMPORE. TERM YEAH AND- UP
SOMETHING THAT I STILL FONG SO.
DO APPRECIATE YOU GUYS COMING
FORWARD FROM WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE EIGHTEEN TEN AND
THANK YOU. FOR WE WILL NOW TAKE
COME ON IS. EIGHTEEN THANKS I'M
CORNY MULHEARN PEARSON WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
ALSO CO CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
AB ALLIANCE ON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MA'AM. HELLO TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
JERRY AT NON THIS WITH THE LAST
SELDOM CENTER STRONG THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS I THANK
YOU MISTER FOR HEARING US IS
AND AS YOU KNOW BEING A FIRST
RESPONDER THIS INCREDIBLE.
BUDGET SHE NEEDS THAT THEN SO
WE- I ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
UPPER. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE A
OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FROM TO. WITH THAT WILL MOVE.
NUMBER FOUR WE TO ISSUE FONG.
I'D TO SURE IN SEE IF THEY ANY.
COM ON THIS ONE THROUGH. WE'RE
GETTING INTO THE RHYTHM OF SUB
ONE THIS YEAR SO. ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES ONE THROUGH
FOUR. I GET AFTERNOON MICHELLE
GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO AND
MAKE A QUICK NOTE ABOUT THE
INTENDED USE OF THE FORTY
MILLION LAST YEAR SO FOLKS ARE
ON THE GROUNDS THAT THE MONEY
HAS NOT RULED OUT YET BUT THERE
ARE THERE IS INTENT. TO USE IT
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS ONE THING
TO MENTION IS THAT IT MADE IT
RIGHT TO THINK ABOUT LONG TERM
STAFFING CAPACITY BECAUSE IT IS
ONE TIME FUNDING AND WHEN OUR
FOLKS HAVE CLICK LEVEL HAVE TO
BUDGET THAT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
TO PLAN FOR AND BUT WHAT I WILL
SAY IS THAT FOLKS ARE LOOKING.
FOR INVESTMENTS IN YOU'LL LAB
CITY ELAINE. AT WILL CLINICS IS
A NOT THAT WE GET OUT INTO THE
TOTHE SCREENING PREVENTION
SERVICES WHETHER THAT'S A S. T.
OR- OTHER TYPES OF SCREENING
AND PREVENTED SERVICES AS WELL
SO WE ARE LOOK AT WAYS TO THE
CITY. WILL AT. AT A TIME MORE
ISN'T TO BUILD UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AS YOU'RE A-
ABOUT IT. SHARKS MAKE A NOTE TO
THINK ABOUT WORK. WHILE SO TO
RESPOND TO IN FACT DISEASES YOU
NOT ONLY NEED TO HAVE RESEARCH.
AND OF THAT THAT THE- PIECE OF
THE INFO. AND WHICH YOU NEED
SKILL SET. ADD TO DRIVE THAT
CAN PASS SO JUST WHY TO MAKE
NOTE THAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. SINGLE FURTHER
PUBLIC. ON ISSUE ONE THROUGH
FOUR WE WILL MOVE. TO FIVE.
AGAIN RICHARD MYSELF I'M CA
MITCHELL DEBBIE TO CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH IN WITH THE
INSTRUCTOR ALL THE FROM ONE OF
OUR DIVISION GENET DISEASE
SCREENING BROKE. PROGRAM GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M RICHARD ONLY A
THE VISION FOR TONIGHT'S THE
SCREENING PROGRAM ALSO KNOW AS
TO THE- SO I'M JUST GONNA PRESS
S. FOR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND ESTIMATE
AND GOVERNOR'S BY SHOWS
TOTALING. OF A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION WHICH AS YOU KNOW
ARE FOR SUPPORTED THROUGH THE
CHEN DISEASE TEST FUN. THIS
TOTAL IS VIRTUALLY ON. FROM THE
NAY TO BUDGET ACT. OF OUR TOTAL
X. APPROX 80% ARE FOR US. OUR
LOCAL SYSTEMS FONG SUPPORT. FOR
THE NEWBORN SCREENING PROGRAM
IN THE PRENATAL SCREENING
PROGRAM AND FOR OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT. FOR THE UPCOMING BUT
YOU'RE THE OUR ESTIMATE SHOWS
AN OVERALL SLIGHT DECREASE AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE WITH A VERY
SMALL CHANGE IN PRENATAL
SCREENING EXPENDITURES TUTOR
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS. DECREASE
SPENDING FOR OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT DUE TO A DROP OFF IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR NEW
INSTRUMENTS AND DATABASE
UPGRADES. IN AN INCREASE IN
NEWBORN SCREENING EXPENDITURES.
SO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
WERE WE'LL BE ADDING A NEW
CONDITIONS SPINAL MUSCULAR
ATROPHY OR SMA. TO THE
CALIFORNIA NEWBORN SCREENING
PANEL BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY.
AND THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA'S STATUTORY
PROVISIONS FOR EXPANDING
SCREENING BECAUSE SMA WAS ADDED
TO THE FEDERAL RECOMMENDED
UNIFORM SCREENING PANEL IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS WHEN WE
ADDED TO OTHER NEW DISORDERS TO
THE CALIFORNIA PANEL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE'RE PROJECTING
INCREASED EXPENDITURES AND THE
ARE COMING FISCAL YEAR FOR
NEWBORN SCREENING. NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF
SCREENING ITSELF BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF COSTS THAT WE COVER
FOR FOLLOW UP A CASE MANAGEMENT
AND COORDINATION- FOLLOW UP
CENTERS DIAGNOSTIC TESTING FOR
SCREEN POSITIVE INFANTS. AND
SYSTEM UPGRADES. THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACTS INCLUDED
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION AND ONGOING
COSTS FOR SMA SCREENING. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN NO FEE INCREASE
TO COVER INCREASED EXPENDITURES
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS
THE LAST TIME DISORDERS ARE
ADDED TO OUR PANEL. SO WE ARE
NOW PROJECTING A NEED FOR A
NEWBORN SCREENING FEE INCREASE
TO SUPPORT. ONGOING SMA SCREEN
CAUSES WAS OFFSETTING INCREASE
FOLLOW ACROSS FOR NEW DISORDERS
IDENTIFIED THROUGH EXPANDED
NEWMAN SCREENING. IT'LL BE A
25% A FEW INCREASE HER NEWBORN
SCREENING ONLY- WHICH WILL BE
NEEDED BEGINNING IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THIS WOULDBE
APPROVED THROUGH THE USUAL RULE
MAKING PROCESS. I WITH US
INCREASE OUR TOTAL REVENUES
WITH THAT INCREASED BY
APPROXIMATELY 12% AND THE
UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR. AND THAT
WILL MORE CLOSELY ALIGN OUR
REVENUES WHETHER EXPENDITURES.
AND THE AMOUNT OF THIS PROPOSED
FEE INCREASE WILL ALSO IMPROVE
THE GSP FUND CONDITION AND
BALANCE NEED REVENUES FROM THE
PRENATAL AND NEWBORN SCREENING
SIDES OF GDS P. THE REVENUE
CALCULATIONS ARE BASED ON OUR
CASE FOR PROJECTIONS FOR THE
UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR WHICH IS
FOR APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND BIRTHS STATEWIDE
AND THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PRENATAL SCREENING PROGRAM. AND
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALEJO. ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE. SEEN
NONO BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- I DO APPRECIATE-
SENATOR POUNDS WORK ON THIS AND
HIS PREVIOUS LEGISLATION SB TEN
NINETY FIVE IT DOES MAKE IT
MUCH EASIER FOR US TO DETERMINE
WHICH- DISEASE AS WE SHOULD BE
SCREENING FOR AND IT DOES SEEM
APPROACH IT WITH THE FUNDING
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
FEES TO CONSIDER THAT THIS
YEAR. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
YOU FIVE OPEN BOND IS SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GIVE.
GOOD
AFTERNOON ADRIN BRONSON SYSTEM
DIVISION CHIEF THE OFFICE OF
AIDS. I'M SORRY IT STARTED WITH
A VERY BRIEF- OVERVIEW OF OUR-
AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
NOVEMBER ESTIMATE. SO IT UP IS
CURRENTLY FUNDED THROUGH THE
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AND A DEPUTY
FUND. FOR FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED EIGHT UP
LOCAL SYSTEMS FUNDING OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION. WITH NO STATE
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION. THE
REVISED CURRENT YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET IS FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION. WHICH IS A DECREASE OF
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION OR
FOUR PERCENT. WHEN COMPARED TO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET AT.
THE NET DECREASE HERE IS
PRIMARILY DUE TO A DECREASE AND
PROJECTED MEDICATION
EXPENDITURES PARTIALLY OFFSET.
BY PROJECTED INCREASE IN
PRIVATE INSURANCE MEDICAL OUT
OF POCKET EXPENDITURES. CHANGES
ARE TO ADD UP BUDGET ALREADY
WHEN COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT INCLUDE. A
DECREASE OF EIGHT POINT
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS AN INCREASE OF
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND EIGHT
APTLY BUT FUN. FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- PROPOSED
EIGHT OUT LOCAL SYSTEMS
FUNDING. EFFORT BUDGET YEAR IS
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF EIGHTEEN MILLION OR
FOUR PERCENT. COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND
AN INCREASE OF THIRTY SIX POINT
TWO MILLION WILL COMPARE TO THE
REVISED COPY OR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY ESTIMATE. THE NET
DECREASE HERE AS PRIMARILY DUE
TO A PROJECTED INCREASE. IN
INSURANCE PREMIUM AND MEDI CAL
EXCUSE ME MEDICAL OUT OF POCKET
EXPENDITURES. PARTIALLY OFFSET
BY PROJECTED DECREASE IN
MEDICATION EXPENDITURES.
CHANGES TO IT UPS BUDGET
AUTHORITY WILL COMPARE TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. ON
INCLUDE A DECREASE OF TWENTY
ONE POINT NINE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS. AN INCREASE OF THIRTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION EIGHT
OPERATE A FUNDS. THAT'S BOND.
LITTLE OVER EIGHT OCULAR
APPROXIMATELY TWO NINE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED A FIVE RECEIVED
DOCTOR. AND FISCAL YEAR A
NINETEEN RESULTS THAT
300-002-0011 INDIVIDUALS WERE
RECEIVE SERVICES IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY AND
300-005-0020 SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WERE RECEIVE SERVICES IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THEN
WE HAVE SOME A FEW THAT TOUCH
MILDLY ON AT THE AND- FUNDING
BUT NOTHING VERY. THE NOVEMBER
S. THANK YOU SIR DEPART OF
FINANCE ALEJO. PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIX. SEEING NONO BRING
IT BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
LATER ON WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM AND THE EPIDEMICS AND- ONE
OF THE WORDS I HEARD FROM THEM
LEARN FROM THEM USED WITH THEM
WAS SEND THEM BACK. THE SYNERGY
THAT HAPPENS BETWEEN EPIDEMICS
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
REORGANIZATION THAT'S CURRENTLY
GOING ON WITHIN CITY PH TO HELP
WITH BOTH HIV HABSI AND STDS.
HI DOCTOR ABA DREW JOHNSON FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SOME ANIMAL WOULD- WE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
A INTEGRATION OF THE OFFICE OF
VIRAL HEPATITIS THE SG CONTROL
BRANCH IN THE OFFICE OF H.
WE'VE DONE. SOME INFORMAL
INTEGRATION OVER THE YEARS
INCLUDING WORKING WITH OUR
SURVEILLANCE HAVE GOTTEN
TOGETHER OR- PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS- CO
APPLYING FOR SOME OF OUR
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL. THAT
BEING SAID I THINK THEY'RE
STILL GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
STREAMLINE OUR OPERATIONS THAT
WILL HELP US INTERNALLY AND
THAT WILL BE QUITE TO A MORE
EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS AT THE BOOTH GROUND
HER DOING THIS WORK. AS WILLING
AS WELL AS HAVING A MORE-
STRATEGIC PROCESS INTERNALLY IF
WE KIND OF FORMALIZED TENSION
ONLY HAVING UNDER ONE ROOF AND
WHAT VERSION- UP. WE'RE AT CON
ARTIST THE PUSH HERE. WE
CONTRACTED WITH A CAN. TO HELP
US IN I DO. A BEST BIZ PRACTICE.
AND A ORGAN IS. SO THAT WE HOPE
WILL. UNDER WANTED BY THE IN OF
THE COUNTER YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH SOME FOR. CHANGE
MAN. AND WE THINK THEY AFTER BY
THE END OF THE COUCH. WILL HOW
A STRUCTURAL BE UNDERWAY ROOF.
AND THEN HAVE A IMPLEMENT.
PHASE OVER THE SEVERAL AFTER
THAT GOING INTO THE NEW CAL
YEAR. NO WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND- LOOK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STILL ON IT. YEAH
WITHIN. THE SENATE YOU DON'T.
WANNA THE- FOR THE MALL. AND SO
AT SOME POINT ACTUALLY HAVE TO
AT THIS G. THAT BURNS WITHIN
THE APPETITE. AND WHAT COULD DO
A AS A MORE. TELL THAT WITH
THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX AND
MOVE ON ISSUES. PERFECT SO
MOVING TO OUR UP IN SO MAKING
OP AND SUPPORT C. P. THIS
REQUEST NINE HIS. AND POINTS
MINE SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
EIGHT EVERYBODY FRONT START
FIST YEAR TWO TWENTY ONE. AND
ANYA THEIR OUT TO PER FOR OUR
GOING MAINTENANCE ON OP. OF THE
EIGHT UP IN ROME SYSTEM. THE A.
S. WAS IN THERE TO. AS AN
INTERIM SO TO SOME EIGHT.
BENEFITS MANAGED. IN MARCH OF
TWO SEVENTEEN DUE TO THE
EMERGENCY NAY OF ITS CREATION
INTERNET YES NO LIVE A- MINIMAL
SALUTE. WILL BE FOUND BODY MASS
TO MANAGE EIGHT OUT. AND
ENROLLMENT AND. OVER TIME
CHANGE FOR IMPLEMENTED TO MEET
THE OF CA. ENROLLMENT WERE AND
OP. ENJOY TWENTY EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
APPROVED THE SERIES OF A YES
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOW
C. PH. TO USE THE A. S. AS A
DOUBTS LAUNCH FOR. FOUR ATOPIC
ROMAN BENEFITS. THE PROJECT
REAL LIFE LIKE WITH IN OCTOBER
TWENTY NINTH. SINCE THE A S. AS
INITIAL ON. OF HEALTH WERE ALSO
ABLE TO THE SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE NEW PROGRAMS AND
EXPANDED IT UP SERVICES
APPROVED PREVIOUSLY BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
THESE ENHANCEMENTS ARE
DRASTICALLY INCREASED
REQUIREMENTS ON BOTH PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFF AND VENDORS IN THE
PAST THREE YEARS FEEDBACK FROM
ENROLLMENT WORKERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAS HELPED C. PH
STREAMLINE IT UP ELIGIBILITY
ENROLLMENT ACTIVITIES
OPTIMIZING. EXCHANGE WITH
EXTERNAL VENDORS AND INSURE IT
UP CLIENTS CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
HIGH QUALITY SERVICE DELIVERY
IN ACCESS TO LIVE SEVEN SAVING
MEDICATIONS. THANK YOU SIR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OLEO.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES SEVEN.
THE CRIPPLES FOR A KELLY HEALTH
HERE IN SUPPORT. CORD AMONG HER
PEERS AND SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT REALLY
THINK THE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU SEE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING
IT BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE- I
WILL COMMENT THAT. I WAS HERE
IN MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHEN WE HAD AN EXTERNAL VENDOR
AND APPRECIATE THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO BRING IT IN HOUSE AND
PROVIDE BETTER QUALITY WITH-
THIS INTERIM ENROLLMENT SYSTEM.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE SEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE IT. PERFECT SO CITY PH AS
PER AN TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TO ALLOW THE PRE
PROPHYLAXIS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
TO PAY FOR INITIAL THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY OF PREP AND POST
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS MEDICATION.
CURRENT STATUTE LIMITS THE QUAN
QUANTITY OF PRESCRIPTIONS UNDER
THE FOLLOWING TWO SCENARIOS.
PREP OUT MAY FURNISH UP TO
FOURTEEN DAYS A PROP AND
MEDICATION AND BE. OUT MAY
FURNISH UP TO TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
OF PET MEDICATION FOR VICTIMS
OF SEXUAL ABUSE. PROVIDERS GOOD
BETTER UNTIL RECENTLY TO WAS
ALL THE APPROVED MEDICATION FOR
PROP AND IS A COMPONENT AND THE
FIRST LINE- RECOMMENDED-%
PEPPERIDGE INLAND. GILEAD
SCIENCES IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY
MANUFACTURER OF PROVIDE A AND
ONLY PACKAGES TREMONT AND
BOTTLES CONTAINING THIRTY
TABLETS. AMONG THE FDA'S
EXPECTATIONS IS THAT ENTITIES
REPACKAGING DRUGS ABOUT DRUG
PRODUCTS DO SO IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE HANDLING AND STORAGE
INSTRUCTIONS PROVIDED AND THE
FDA APPROVED- LABELING THE
PACKAGE INSERT FOR- THE
MANUFACTURE PROVIDER
SPECIFICALLY INSTRUCTS TO ONLY
DISPENSED IN THE ORIGINAL
CONTAINER. ADDITIONALLY THE
MANUFACTURER HAS BEEN SENDING
LETTERS THREE PACKAGERS
EXPLICITLY INSTRUCTING THEM-
NOT THE SPORT MODELS OF
PROVIDER. THERE ARE CONCERNS
THAT WHEN A BOTTLE OF TREMONT
IS OPEN IT DRASTICALLY REDUCES
THE SHELF LIFE TO SIX WEEKS. SO
NATURALLY WE DO NOT WANT TO
DISPENSE MEDICATION THAT IS
ASKED TO BE EXPIRED INDIVIDUALS.
SO DUE TO THESE BARRIERS TO
PROPER AS A NEIGHBOR TO ALBUM
THIS PER IS FROM BY LAW. AND.
WE ARE RE TO DISPENSE THIRTY
DAY RICHMOND. THE BERMAN
FINANCE OKAY. PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE A. HI ACCORDING TO PAIRS
OF THE SAME AIDS FOUNDATION
AGAIN YOU WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
CRIPPLE STRAIGHT KELLY HEALTH
pSAID WITH GLIDE IN SAN
FRANCISCO INSTRUCTS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SO I JUST GOT THE
TEXT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS HERE WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NOT. AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER TO TRAILER BILL WE ARE
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
FOR ELECTRONIC RETRIEVAL OF
AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
CLIENTS MODIFIED ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME OR MAGI. DATA FROM THE
CUT CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THAT EIGHT UP USE AN
APPLICANT'S MET DRIVE FOR
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY. CURRENT
LAW ONLY ALLOWS FTV FOR THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO PROVIDE
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME WHICH IS
NOT INCLUDE HOUSEHOLD DATA
NECESSARY TO CALCULATE MATCH
I'D- WELL FCV CURRENTLY HOUSE
ALL THEINFORMATION NECESSARY
TO ASSESS HOUSEHOLD MATCH AYE.
FE BE SENSE TAX DATA ALL LEAVE
FOR A DIAL UP FOR THE APP
APPLET SEE PH PROPOSES AMENDING
AND SAFE CODE. TWELVE ZERO NINE
SIX TWO AND REVENUE TELL CODE
SECTION NINETEEN OF A FIVE
EIGHT POINT TWO TO ANSWER THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION OF HOUSE.
AND FAMILY SIZE DO PROPOSED
CHANGES WHAT STREAMLINED DATA
COLLECTION ELIMINATE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND
ELIMINATE CONFLICTS AND CURRENT
LAW. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA-
OKAY. PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
NINE. CREDIBLE STRAIGHT KELLY
HEALTH IN SUPPORT. COURTNEY
WILL HER PEARSON SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT OR BRING IT UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
NINE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TEN.
SO ISSUE TEN- ASK FOR AN
UPDATE ON- THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND AUG
AUGMENTATION THAT WAS AWARDED
VIA THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
OUT. SOLVE START WITH THE- HIV
PORTION OF THE ALLOCATION AND
ALL- HANDED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO TOUCH ON THE
REST- SO FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION A AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
A GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION WAS
AWARDED THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT AND OVER THE SUMMER
AND INTO THE EARLY FALL WE
INITIATED A SERIES OF. SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS- IN ORDER
IN ORDER TO- IDENTIFY- AND
EFFICIENT AND EXPEDIENT PROCESS
TO ALLOCATE THESE MONIES TO-
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEEDED IT. I SO
WITH THAT WE ALSO- LOOK THAT
SURVEILLANCE DATA EXTENSIVELY
TO IDENTIFY WHERE THE CRITICAL
NEED WAS A GALA KATE THESE
MONIES. AND WE BEGAN ON- A
COMPETITIVE RFA PROCESS- WHICH-
PRIORITIZES INDIVIDUALS IS
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF
ACQUIRING HIV. A THAT IS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE A LOT NEXT
ORDER MEMBERS IN THE BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY. AND
THE ARE THEY FOCUS ON PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE HIV PREVENTION
AND CONTROL SERVICES TO THESE-
POPULATIONS. WE RECEIVED FIFTY
FIVE APPLICATIONS FROM A
MIXTURE OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. AND WE
ABORTED IT- FIFTEEN AWARDS AND
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING INDIVIDUALLY WITH
THESE ENTITIES TO DEVELOP
INDIVIDUAL SCOPES OF WORK WITH
THE HOPES OF EXECUTING
CONTRACTS VERY SHORTLY- SO THAT
WE CAN BEGIN HAVING THOSE
MONIES DISPERSED. IF WE CAN
MOVE ON TO THE- THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE CONTROL
NEXT. MY NAME IS SANKALP ONE
DAY AND THE ASSISTANT DIVISION
CHIEF FOR THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE CONTROL
AND THAT WE RECEIVED AND THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE
TIME FUNDING OVER FOUR YEARS.
AND THEN WE WITH THOSE FUND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION WILL GO TO
THE LOCAL HEALTH ALL SIXTY ONE
LOCAL CULTURE SECTIONS AND THE
INTENT OF THESE FUNDS FOR TO BE
AS MAXIMALLY TAXABLE AS
POSSIBLE AND- WE WILL. WE
DESIGN IT TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR COMPONENT OF COMMUTE
DISEASE INFO INFRASTRUCTURE
BEING SURVEY AND I ONE
ENHANCING EVALUATION AND
MONITORING OF OUR PREVENTION
PROGRAMS- IN FOR THE LAST
MINUTE TODAY TODAY OR SEARCH
FOR OUTBREAKS AND ALSO
PURCHASES OF LABORATORY OR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TO
IMPROVE- OUR RESPONSE. AND WE
HAVE ALL THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THEIR GRANT
DOCUMENTATION IN HAND AND TODAY
A BIKE OF BUSINESS ACTUALLY
WHEN THOSE ARE DUE TO US IN THE
TO. HAVE THOSE IN PLACE BY THE
END OF THE YEAR SOTHE FUNDING
CAN GO OUT RISE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. I'M ADDITIONALLY
MILLION WAS TO GO TO ENHANCE
ARE. TO TROUBLE COMMITTEE AND
WE HAVE A WERE WORKING ON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN ROLE
HEALTH BOARD- TO IMPROVE AND
ENHANCE THE COLLECTION OF DATA
FOR REGARDING THE NEW AMERICAN
POP. ASKING I'M AND THIS WILL
BE HOLDING SEVERAL STE. GROUPS
TO KIND OF HELP US. DEFINE WHAT
THE FOR WE WANT TO COLLECT AND
CONNECTED ALREADY SURVEILLANCE
STATUS IS SO THAT WE HAVE MORE
ACCURATE DATA TO REFLECT THAT
POPULAR XIN. BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THIS FOR HOW COMMUNITY AYE
MAN FOR YOU REACH A TO MY SEAT
MATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ARE
FIRST NIGHT OF A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND MAY HAVE SOME
INSIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
WITH THAT PROGRAM AS IT'S GOING
OUT. WITH THAT IF WE CAN HEAR
FOR THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES NEXT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MONICA MORALIS FOR
THE RECORD. I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS- COUPLE PRODUCTS-
COUPLE OF TOPICS ONE ALSO WITH
THE SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM.
OKAY. FOR THE SAKE OF MEDICS
PER RECEIVE A ONE TWO ALLOCATE
OF ONE TO IN BY ACT NINE TWENTY
TO MOVE FORWARD UPDATED STATE
OF AND ALSO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO HIRE THREE F. T.
CURRENTLY AS WE'RE STAND WE HAD
ACTUALLY. GONE INTO CON WITH IN
NINETEEN MANAGEMENT AND DID. IN
OUR TRACK FOR DELAY IN AN
UPDATED BY JUNE TWO TWENTY IN
ADDITION WE HAVE ACTUALLY- JUST
RECENTLY HIRED ONE OF THE STAFF
IN OUR IN THE PROCESS OF-
HAVING TO INTERVIEWS IN MARCH
FOR THE REMAINING TO STAFF-
ADDITIONALLY PART OF OUR- BIRDS
ARE REALLY TRYING TO. INCREASE
AT THE BETTER USE OF THE
DATABASE. FOR EXAMPLE WE DID AN
ASSESSMENT AT LAST YEAR OF FROM
FEBRUARY TWO- EBERLE WE WERE
ABLE TO CAPTURE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED ERRORS IN THE DATABASE
SO WORK TROUBLESHOOTING WITH
THE NEW I. T. STAFF ON HOW TO
ACTUALLY GET THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE BARRIERS. IN THAT THE NEW
SYSTEM WILL BE ABLE TO- BE A
LITTLE MORE FRIENDLY BOTH TO
THE PUBLIC BY BEING ABLE TO
FILTER INFORMATION DOWN BY
INGREDIENT OR PRODUCT AND ALSO
FOR THE COMPANY'S. BEEN ABLE TO
ACTUALLY NOT HAVE TO. EACH TIME
THAT THEY GO INTO THE DATABASE
STARTED NEW FORM AND IT YOU
KNOW ICLUDE THE SAME
INFORMATION OVER AND OVER BUT
JUST HAVE AN ONGOING PROCESS
WITH EASIER FOR THEM TO ENTER
THE DATA TO HAVE MULTIPLE USES
ON THEIR ACCOUNT. AND THEN FROM
A REPORTING STANDPOINT FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO EASILY REPORT
INFORMATION WITHOUT HAVING TO
DO IT MANUALLY. FINALLY JUST
REPORTING THAT FOR US OUR
EFFORT IS TO ACTUALLY ALSO HAVE
MORE REPORTS- ON OUR WEBSITE
INTO WORK A LITTLE CLOSER. WHAT
SOME OF- YOU KNOW THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY COMPANIES TO ACTUALLY
INFORM THEM OF THEIR MANDATE
AND ALSO TO INFORM THEM OF- THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ON THE
WEBSITE TO THE PUBLIC SOME.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FOR THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY.
SORRY TO PLAY MUSICAL CHAIRS
BUT I USUALLY JUST GO DOWN THE
LIST A PANELIST THE WAY I FIND
IT EASIEST. RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CERTAINLY
SCHIRMER SOME THE SYSTEM THAT
DIRECTOR THE OFFICE HEALTH
EQUITY. IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH RECEIVE SEVENTEEN
POINT FINALLY GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT ACTIVITIES THAT ADDRESS
LESBIAN BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER
AND QUEER WOMEN'S HEALTH
DISPARITIES. ACTIVITY FUNDED BY
THIS INITIATIVE INCLUDE
INNOVATION DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS AND EVALUATION
LOCALIZE COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TOO MANY LET
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
LAUNCHING OF A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN AND THE CONDUCTING OF
RESEARCH ON LBT Q. WOMEN'S.
DETERMINE IF OF HEALTH HOW
RELATED QUALITY OF LIFE. LAUGHS
LAST MONTH AFTER THIS IS THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY TO
MANAGE WHO WILL. THE LBT WANT
TO SELL INITIATIVE. THIS
INDIVIDUAL WHO OVERSEE THE
INITIATIVE RECENT FOR IN THE
HEALTH POLICY REFORM.
DEPARTMENT OF. WHERE HE SPENT
IN LGBT HELL. ACCESS TO CARE
BONOBO COMMUNITY. IN THIRD OF
DEPARTMENT SO TO MATTER AT ON
IS RELATED TO TRANSFER. NON
BINDING AND GENDER LOCK AND CL.
THIS IN THE ALSO PROVED SERVED
AS THE HELL POLICY FOR THE
TRANSGENDER LAW CENTER. AND AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA BEFORE THAT. WE
ARE EXCITED TO FIND SOMEONE
WITH THIS INDIVIDUALS. TO MOVE
OR WORK FOR THOUGHTFULLY AND
WHAT DO SPEED IN ADDITION THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY IS
ACTIVELY RECRUITING FOR TWO
POSITIONS TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
INITIATIVE. AND ACTIVELY
WORKING ON DESIGNING THIS
INITIATIVE TO MAXIMUM IMPACT.
THIS INCLUDES STUFF SUCH AS
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS
DEVELOPING GOALS AND PUTTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO LINK THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS. OF THE NATIONAL FOR
MAXIMUM IMPACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
GONNA COME INTO WELL ON THE
CIRCLE CELL DISEASE TREATMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE OR IF THAT
SOMEONE ELSE. HELP THE
COMMUNITY. TO GIVE MORE CHAIR
RIGHT. ERIC SO AS FOR MY IN THE
BUDGET ACT TWENTY NINE THIS SO
TO FOUNDER OF CAL. IN THE
CENTER FOR HEARING BLOOD IS WE
A TIME TO FUND ALLOCATION OF
FIFTEEN DOLLAR. AS CITY PH
RECEIVES THE DOLLARS MISTER THE
FINE AND FOURTEEN THREE AND
FORTY THOUSAND WITH PAID BY
DIRECT. TO THE CENTER FOR HEAD
OF THE A HE SAID AND IT THERE
WAS AN ALLY OF HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO PH I. IN NOVEMBER OF THIS
YEAR FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE CENTERS ARE MOVING FORWARD
IN ESTABLISH WAR PLANS WITH
COUNTIES OF CURRENT SAN
BERNARDINO ALAMEDA SACRAMENTO
AND SAN DIEGO. IF WORK. IS TO
REALLY DEVELOP COORDINATED
SERVICE FOR SO CELL DISEASE IN
IT P. H. I. IS ACTIVELY TO X.
THEIR DATA COLLECTION FOR TWO
TO HOSP DISTRICTS TO EMERGENCY
FOR RECORDS AND MEDICAID CLAIMS
SPECIFICALLY THEY'RE TRYING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF YEARS OF
THESE DATA SETS. WE ARE
EXPECTED TO SEE- ANNUAL REPORTS
AND THE FINAL REPORT WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DPARTMENT BY
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU AND FINALLY WE HAVE
THE FARM WORKER HEALTH STUDY SO
THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES YOU TO ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF ONE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TWO
AND A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY TO
IMPROVE FORMER. CALIFORNIA CITY
PAGE RCEIVED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TO ADMINISTER
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THIS EFFORT. THE REMAINING
ONE MILLION THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND IS GOING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF COURSE. TO
IMPLEMENT THE STUDY WE'RE ON
FINALIZING THE NOW INITIAL BE
IN PLAY BY MAY TWENTY TWENTY.
HOWEVER THERE IS ME HAVE ACT
TAKE PLACE ACROSS STATE TO
REALLY GATHER INPUT ON WHAT
THIS DESIGN WILL LOOK LIKE.
DISH THERE MOVIE SO WHAT THE
MATH TO ALL WILL LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE A RIGHT NOW THAT THERE
SURVEY OF A THOUSAND FIVE
FARMWORKERS THEY WILL KIND FIVE
PHYSICALIST ON OF THEM AND THEY
PLANT OVERSEE. OF WHAT IN THE
FIELD ALL AT THE FIRST SO WE'RE
HOPING TO BE CONDUCT SOME OF
THE PRIME DATA IN JANUARY OF.
TWO TWENTY. BY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OLEO. PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE TEN. AND I CAN'T DO WORK
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE EARLIER
COMMENTS OF- MICHELLE GIVEN
THAT THE HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ABOUT THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT FUNDING FOR A
COUPLE DISEASE PREVENTION IT
HELPS MAKE ME BUSSMANN. BUT
WILL BE REALLY IS ON THINGS CAN
HELP PEOPLE ON THE GO. WE NEED
KNOW WHEN THE NAY AB IS TO THE
NATURAL DISASTER WE NEED PEOPLE
WHO ARE YOU TRAIN. OR IN OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. THE I
THINK THAT IS ASSOCIATION HOW
FOR JUST WANTED TO MAKE A QUICK
NOTE A THAT THE FUNDING IN AT
IT AS YOU'VE NOTED ALREADY THAT
ACTIONS THESE DOLLARS ARE STILL
LOOKING GO OUT FOR A COUPLE
TING ALLOCATIONS WE'RE APPROVED
LAST YEAR INCLUDING BACK IN THE
HEALTH. SITTING THAT AS WELL
THE WEED OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FUN GO
AWAY THAT THERE'S A TO ROLL THE
PHONE OVER IF WE'RE NOT ABLE
GET HIM OUT AND- THANK YOU FOR.
POST FOR HEALTH HIV PREVENTION
LAST YEAR I THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ITS WORK IN ENSURING THAT
FUNDING WAS INCLUDED AND THE
OFFICE OF A TICKET IN THAT FUND
NOW- ESPECIALLY MAKING SURE
IT'S GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES
IN POPULATION HAS IMPACTED I
JUST KNOW IN A- IN. SAYS IT'S
FOUR POINT I POINT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY RECEIVED
OVER SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
APPLICATIONS AND SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS A MUCH LARGER ON
UNFULFILLED NEED. AND THAT NEED
IS REFLECTED IN THE DATA THANKS
THANK YOU SIR. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP HERE ON AN ITEM
THAT IS NOT ON THE AGENDA TODAY
BUT AS PART OF A FAMILY HEALTH
ESTIMATE REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA HOME. PROGRAM HAPPY
WITH THE IN. IN AN ON COURT
THROUGH THE INCREASE FROM LAST.
WE HAVE A NUMBER COUNTIES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN PART OF THE
WAITING AND HAVE A SHORTFALL IN
TERMS OF THEIR OWN BUDGETS ON
HOME VISITING RIGHT NOW. TO
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE ON THE
DISCUSSIONS AND FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION. YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC. AND REMEMBER
WHAT. YES AND THAT'S JUST A
QUESTION- REGARDING THE MONEY
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH TECH TO. FOR THE
COUNT FOR THE- INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE AND INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PREVENTION CONTROL RIGHT WHY
HASN'T IT BEEN RELEASED. WERE
NINE MONTH ALMOST AND WERE
EIGHT MONTHS SINCE THE BUDGET
WAS SIGNED. Y. EIGHT Y. THAT
MONEY BAILABLE. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE'VE HAD A AT
THE OR IN RECENT YEARS AS AND
WE'VE HAD TO DISTRIBUTE MONEY
TO LOOK FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
SO WE CAN DO THIS SYSTEM STAFF
WHICH I'M AND THEN WE HELD A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT CALL HOME
CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE CREATING ALLOCATE AN
INDUSTRY. THE FUNDING NEEDED TO
GO ALL RIGHTS USING THE RIGHT.
AS COMPONENTS TO PUT THAT OUT
TOGETHER AND NOW THAT WE HAVE
ALL THE- ALL THE DOCUMENTS
TOGETHER. AND ALSO RECEIVED A
COUPLE OF REQUEST YOU PUSH BY
THE DEATH IN FOR THE FOR THE
CONTRACT TO COME BACK IN WHICH
WE- WHICH ONE. WE WERE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ACCOMMODATE THE-
TEXANS WELL IN THAT REGARD AND
AT THIS POINT A LOT OF OUR-
COUNTIES ARE ALSO. ASKING TO
PUSH THOSE DEADLINES BACK
BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS. AND THE
WERE WORKING REALLY TRYING TO.
PLUS AND- ONE UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN GET THAT FUNDING
NOW AS QUICK AS SO NO FUNDING
IS GONE OUT YET AND FINING HAS
GONE SO IF YOU'RE A COUNTY
THAT'S GOT YOUR PRIDE IN ITS
ALL PRUDENT READY. WE NEED THE
GRANT DOCUMENTS TO COME BACK
WHAT EFFECT ARE THERE ARE THERE
NO COUNTIES. THAT HAVE
COMPLETED THE. HAD ANOTHER MID
FEBRUARY DAY IT WHICH THEY
ASKED ALSO TO EXTENDED TO MARCH
SECOND WHICH WE WHICH WE
ACCOMMODATED. AND AT I THINK I
THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT THERE'S
ALSO. THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
STAFF TO KIND OF PROCESS A LOT
OF THESE THINGS AT ONCE AND IT
WAS NOT ONLY THESE FUNDS BUT
THERE IS S. T. FUNDS HCV FINDS
EIGHT. THE FUNDS AND A LOT OF
THE THESE THINGS IMPACT THE
SAME. FOLKS AT THE COUNTIES-
AND SO IT JUST I THINK IT WAS
AN OVERWHELMING. YEAR FOR THEM
IN A GOOD WAY. WELL YEAH I
GUESS BUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED
THAT THE MONEY'S NOT GETTING
OUT BECAUSE THERE'S A NEED AND
YOU KNOW AND SO I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU GONNA WAIT TO
LOBBY COUNTY HAS EVERYTHING
TOGETHER AND WE ARE PUTTING
MONEY OUT BECAUSE AT ABSOLUTELY
NO WE HAVE ONE WE DID. WE DO
HAVE ONE CONTRACT THAT CAME
BACK AND WE IMMEDIATELY PROCESS
THAT SO IT'S ON A FLOW BACK. AS
SOON AS THEY COME IN WERE
PROCESSING THOSE DOT. TO GET
FUNDS WITH. THE BALL. AND THE-
BILL IN ONE LUMP SUM SO ONCE
THE GRANT DOT. ALL RISE. THANK
IT. HIGHER MATH OF THE FUNDS
USE. THAT TIME TO ADDRESS AND
ANSWER. IN OUR IN OUR CULTURE
SO. THANK YOU SHE HAD A CALM
I'D LIKE TO THAT'S A TO THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU. WANT TO
CLARIFY ADD THE HARD WORK OF
THE THAT THE DOT. ALLOCATION
BEEN SO FOR QUITE TIME IS JUST
TAKING. A OF MONTHS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO GET
THE FUND DOCUMENTS TO. INSTALL
EVEN THE DAM IS TODAY WE HAVE
BEEN. ON THE GUIDANCE FOR AND
MONTHS AT. I MENTIONED AT THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE CAME OUT WAS
VERY WERE. GIVEN SO WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE- TRY TO
GET MORE FOR. WHAT HE SAID.
THAT THE- FOR THE RECORD IT'S
NOT THE- YOU'RE SICK. IS WERE
YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN. THE GRANT
AGREEMENTS FOR SOMETIME ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION I THINK CAME
OUT WITHIN THE LAST MAYBE A
MONTH. AND THEN WE HAD BEEN
WAITING SOME FOR SOME FURTHER
CLEAR. PATIENT YEAH I GUESS I
WOULD JUST GO BACK TO SEEMS
STILL THE WHOLE THING SEEMS
LIKE IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S- TRAIN
THAT HAS A STARTED YET. SO
THAT'S THAT'S- CONSIDERING THE
NEED IN OUR SUMMER COMMUNITIES
IT'S AT THAT'S A LITTLE
SURPRISED THAT IT'S- AS SLOW.
MOVING THAT. THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER WHAT. I DID WANT TO
MENTION A FEW OF THE PROGRAMS
IF YOU CAN AND I THINK IN SOME
WAYS IT'S BECAUSE PUBLIC HEALTH
IS AN AREA THAT- THIS COMMITTEE
IS ALSO QUITE INTERESTED IN
FIGURING OUT HOW TO HELP TO
SUPPORT IT SO- I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING THROUGH MY
COLLEAGUE IS. REAL BILL OF
WANTING A WILDERNESS TO BE ABLE
TO US DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT
HOW BEST TO MAKE SURE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED THAT SAID MANY OF
PROGRAMS WE ORDERED LAST YEAR
WHETHER IT BE FROM S. T. HE'S
THE SEE TO IT. HE ONLY BE. Q.
HELPING GATOR AND SYRINGE
PROGRAMS TO A FARMWORKERS STUDY
REALLY DO START TO GET AT THE
HEALTH INEQUITIES THESE EVEN
SOME OF THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH WHICH DR ANGEL SPOKE
OF AT THE START OF THIS AND SO-
JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE- THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO GET
THOSE FUNDS OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WHILE BEING
RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE FUNDS THAT WE HAVE AS WELL
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TEN OPEN. AND IF I MAY THE NEXT
SIX ITEMS ARE REMEMBER GLORIA
BUT WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND SO AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD INDULGE ME AND ALLOW HIM
TO GO FOR FIRST WE WILL NEXT
YEAR CHOOSE SEVENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR. THIS BILL
ALLOCATE TWENTY MILLION TO THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. SO
THAT THEY CAN ESTABLISH A STATE
WIDE PROGRAM WHICH WILL PROVIDE
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS.
EXPERIENCING SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES. THIS
ISSUE IS NOT NEW BUT AS TO THE
RATES ARE INCREASING ALL ACROSS
THE STATE AMONGSTMEN AND
WOMEN. ESPECIALLY ISN'T
COMMITTEES LIKE THE ONE ON THE
MINUTE WE REPRESENT. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THERE ARE 500-030-0404
REPORTED CASES. OF SURF. TWO
HUNDRED. BUT YOU ONE EIGHTY ONE
REPORTED CASES OF CHLAMYDIA
FORTY MOST OF THIS TO THESE ARE
PREVENTABLE AND CURABLE SO LONG
AS WE HAVE THE RIGHT PROGRAMS
IN PLACE. WITH ALLOCATION OF
THESE FUNDS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE SUCH AS ROUTINE
CONTACT AND FOLLOW UP WITH
CLIENTS. REFERRALS AND
CONNECTIONS TO PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND HEALTH AND
SOCIAL NEEDS ASSESSMENTS. WITH
ME TO TODAY TO TESTIFY IS TRULY
TRULY RAYMONDO DIRECTOR OF THE
SUMMER DO NOT COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NUMBERS MY
NAME IS DETERMINED OF THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
SALMON TINO COUNTY. AND I AM
HERE TODAY FORMALLY TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION COMING FROM THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION. OF CALIFORNIA- AND
THISFUNDING WILL ALLOW LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS A TO PROVIDE
NAVIGATION COORDINATION
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING AYE THE
REINFECTION OR WHAT WE CALL
COMPLEX CASES OF STDS. I'M TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
PERSPECTIVE IN A MEDINA COUNTY
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN A LOT. WE
HAVE A TWELVE HUNDRED CASE
CEPHALUS. OF THOSE THIRTY THREE
WERE ACTUALLY RE INFECTIONS AND
THOUGH THAT MAY SEEM LIKE A
SMALL NUMBER SIXTEEN OF THOSE
THIRTY THREE ACTUALLY
CONTRACTED SYPHILIS MORE THAN
WALKS. ON IN THAT TIME FOR IT.
FREE GOOGLE LIST A GONE FROM A
OF CASES IN TWO IF YOU. A WHAT
WE- ARE WHICH IS A CAR HI. SIX
SIX PROBLEM CASES. INTO
NINETEEN BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
WE ACTUALLY DOUBLED OUR NUMBER
OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS CASES
FROM. THIRTY THREE TO SIXTY
SIX. IN A LOT OF THESE-
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS CASES IN A
LOT OF THESE REINFECTION CASES-
WHAT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH IS
ULTIMATELY THIS COMPLEX WEB OF
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES-
THAT ARE UNDERLYING A LOT OF
THE REASON AND A LOT OF THE
INCREASES- WE ARE EXPERIENCING
CLIENTS THAT ARE DEALING WITH
POVERTY- DEALING WITH
HOMELESSNESS. PRIOR
INCARCERATION SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO CARE
AND OFTENTIMES WE ARE SEEING
SEEING SITUATIONS WHERE CLIENTS
ARE EXCHANGING SEX FOR MONEY
HOUSING AND OTHER RESOURCES.
AND SO ULTIMATELY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT ONLY BEING
DEL BEING ASKED TO DEAL WITH
THE TREATMENT ASPECT- BUT THERE
ARE UNDERLYING ISSUE THAT I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO ADDRESS IN
ORDER TO DO OUR JOB PROPERLY
THE WHOLE TOMORROW. BILLY ARE.
WELL BE ABLE TO DELIVER THESE.
AS WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
AND EXPERTISE BEING ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THE FLOOR VULNERABLE
AND VERY DIFFICULT TO REACH
POPULATIONS. ULTIMATELY THERE
IS NO SPECIFIC FUNDING THAT
ALLOWS US. TO DO THIS KIND OF
WORK AND LIKE THAT I'D LIKE TO
END OFF WITH THE PARTICULAR
CASE THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
RECENTLY AND SALMON DINO- TO BE
ABLE TO PUT KIND OF A FACE TO
THE ISSUE. A WE HAD A THIRTY
FOUR YEAR OLD FEMALE ON THAT
THANK THANKFULLY DID REPORT TO
HER OB GIN- WHEN SHE WAS FOUR
MONTHS PREGNANT- SHE WAS TESTED
AND TYPICALLY CAME UP POSITIVE
FOR SYPHILIS. OF THE WRITER DID
CONTACT THE PUBLIC DEPARTMENT.
AND WE'LL- THE WRITER THE THIS
PARTICULAR PATIENT HER
TREATMENT WOULD BE ONE
INJECTION OF PENICILLIN THAT
NEED TO BE TAKEN EVERY SEVEN
DAYS FOR THREE WEEKS. LEAVE THE
PROVIDER STAFF CONTACT US A FEW
WEEKS LATER BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNABLE TO CONNECT WITH THE
PATIENT. OF THE PROVIDER OUR
OWN STAFF OR COMMUTER WILL
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS THEN WENT
ABOUT THEIR JOB- THEY MADE
MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS THEY SENT
LETTERS TO MULTIPLE ADDRESSES.
AND ACTUALLY WENT OUT INTO THE
FIELD TWICE- IN ORDER TO FIND
THIS PARTICULAR PATIENT- THEIR
PERSISTENCE FINALLY PAID OFF. A
THEY WERE FINALLY ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH THE PATIENT AND
THAT'S WHEN THEY DISCOVERED
THAT THE REAL REASON BEHIND HER
NON COMPLIANCE. WAS
TRANSPORTATION. AS WELL AS
HOMELESSNESS- THROUGH THEIR
EDUCATION THOUGH THEY WERE ABLE
TO EDUCATE THE CLIENT ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE TRANSMISSIBILITY OF
THE DISEASE. FROM THE MOTHER TO
THE FEEDER. WELL SO THE-
CONSEQUENCES THE- THANKS FOR
ALL WE FEEL TO MY- SHE- TO
TREATMENT- THEY WORKED WITH HER
IN ORDER TO MAKE APPOINTMENTS
AND SHE EVEN AGREE TO TAKE THE
BUS- TO HER PARTICULAR
APPOINTMENT. ULTIMATELY THE
PATIENT WENT TO THE APPOINTMENT
AND WHAT WE DISCOVERED LATER
WAS THAT SHE WAS INFORMED
DURING THE APPOINTMENT THAT THE
MEDICATION SHE NEEDED WAS NOT
AVAILABLE. WITH THE PROVIDER
AND THAT HER EMERGENCY MEDICAL
WAS NOT GOING TO COVER THE
TREATMENT WHEN THE PATIENT WAS
RESCHEDULED NOT SURPRISINGLY
SHE DID NOT COMPLY AND SHE DID
NOT WHAT. AGAIN AFTER SEVERAL
ATTEMPTS OUR COMMUNITY WILL
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS WERE BACK
OUT IN THE FIELD- EVENTUALLY
FOUND HER AGAIN AGAIN SHE
AGREED TO TREATMENTS- SHE DID
GO TO TREATMENT SHE DID RECEIVE
THE TREATMENT HOWEVER AFTER THE
TREATMENT OUR PROVIDER
CONTACTED US AGAIN. YES SHE
RECEIVED A TO THE THREE
TREATMENTS BUT HER SECOND DOSE
OF WAS THE INCORRECT AMOUNT.
AND SO WHAT WE WERE LEFT WITH
WAS THAT. OUR COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE INVESTIGATOR THAN HAVE
TO NOTIFY THE PROVIDER BUT THIS
POOR PATIENT HAD TO RETART THE
ENTIRE TREATMENT- AND THAT
ULTIMATELY THE BABY WAS NOW
GOING TO NEED SOME KIND GENTLE
TREATMENT AND FOLLOW UP-
BECAUSE ALL OF THAT NEED TO BE
DONE WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
DELIVERY. WHAT THIS FOR THIS
MOTHER IS THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO
LEAVE THE HOSPITAL WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS BUT HER BABY HAD TO
STAY HOSPITALIZED FOR TEN DAYS
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE IV
TREATMENT AN IV THERAPY. THIS
RESULTED IN A LOT BONDING
BETWEEN THE MOTHER AND THE
CHILD. AND FRANKLY IN CARD
EXTRA THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO A
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FOR WHAT IS
A COMPLETELY PREVENTABLE
DISEASE- THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
LASTED FIVE MONTHS- WHEN
PRESENTED TO OUR BE GENTLE THE
BIRTH OF A BABY THE
INVESTIGATION INVOLVED NUMEROUS
PHONE CALLS- TO A MULTITUDE OF
OUR CONTACTS SEVERAL LETTERS.
MY STAFF WERE OUT IN THE FIELD
TRYING TO TRACK HER DOWN ON-
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S JUST A LOT
OF MEDICAL COVERAGE. IN A PER.
OR NAY EDUCATION AT THE
PROVIDER LEVEL THERE'S
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES THERE WAS
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES ALL OF
THESE RESULTING IN BARRIERS
THAT RESULTED IN A CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS CASE THAT WAS
PREVENTABLE ON SO MANY LEVELS
DESPITE THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
DESPITE ALL THE WORK OF MY
STAFF DID DO WAS WERE THE
THINGS THAT THEY COULD NOT DO
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF FUNDING
THEY WERE NOT A RESULT HER
LISTENING SURE SHE AND THE BABY
COULD RETURN TO A STABLE
ENVIRONMENT- WE'RE NOT. ABLE TO
SOLVE. BEHAVE BUT SHE MAY HAVE
A- IN ORDER TO PUT HER IN THAT
POSITION OR ANY OTHER SOCIAL OR
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT SHE
MAY HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH AND
SO ULTIMATELY SHE MAY END UP
BACK- WITH PUBLIC HEALTH UNDER
INVESTIGATION. AND SO AGAIN
GIVEN THE UNPRECEDENTED A RISE
IN STDS THAT WE ARE SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT- THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION.
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ASK- IN ORDER TO RESOLVE THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE AND THIS
GAP THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SEVENTEEN. MICHELLE
GIVEN THE CHECK AT AS THE CASE
ILLUSTRATED THERE IS A NEED FOR
SOME FUNDING DEDICATED TO THESE
THESE CASES WHERE IT'S HIGH
TOUCH HER HIGH NEED. A WE
RECOGNIZE AND HAVING
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT OUR
MEMBERSHIPS THAT RE AND THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF JURISDICTION
SEEING INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
INFECTIONS AND THEN THERE ARE
ALSO A NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS
IT'S ALL INDIVIDUALS WITH
COMPLEX CASES SO INDIVIDUALS
WITH. A ONE EXAMPLE IS THIRTEEN
STDS AT ONE TIME THERE'S OTHER
COMPLEX CASES WHERE THERE I
ALSO THIS. APARTMENT WOMEN WITH
SYPHILIS WHO REQUIRES A HIGHER
TOUCH- WE RECOGNIZE AND YOU'LL
HEAR MANY. PROPOSALS AFTER US
AROUND STDS EACH TV IN HIV WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BALL WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR TESTING SCREENING A
PREVENTION BUT THERE'S ALSO A
NEED FOR. AT FUNDING DEDICATED
SO THAT WE CAN FOLLOW UP IN
CIRCUMVENT SOME OF THESE-
GREATER SOCIAL ISSUES ISSUES
THAT ARE HAPPENING SUCH AS
HOMELESSNESS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WHERE ART WE'RE SEEING OUR
CLIENTS MULTIPLE TIMES AND IT
COULD BE AT. AT TAKING CARE OF
BY JUST GETTING THEM CONNECTED
TO THE PROPER SERVICES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. KELLY
BROOKS I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. OR IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL I'M I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THERE'S BEEN A 100%
INCREASE IN CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
CASES BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THERE'S BEEN
A TEN FOLD INCREASE IN
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS- CASES
SINCE TWENTY TEN- NOW SEEMS TO
BE A REALLY GOOD TIME TO BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION AND TO
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN-
INVESTMENT. THE PEOPLE AT THE
RIGHT. SERVICES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. CRAIG POSTER FROM A PELE
HEALTH AND STRONG SUPPORT SIR.
QUITE A MULHER PEARSON SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. JENNA HEY WOULD WITH
THE NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WESLEY SERVER WITH
GLIDE INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SO BE CASTEEL WITH
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT. RAND MORE
NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THANK. YOU
SIR. SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS-
I DON'T HAVE ANY DIRECT
QUESTIONS BUT THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF- ISSUES I HAVE WITH THE
ANECDOTE IN WHICH YOU PRESENTED
AND I MAY NEED TO ASK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE LATER. I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACTUALLY ASKING ABOUT THE
SEVEN MILLION ON GOING THAT WE
PROVIDED LAST YEAR. AND FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS PROPOSAL
COMPLIMENTS THAT INCREASE IN
FUNDING. OR DO YOU KNOW HOW
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE USED IN THE
FIRST. THE RETURN ABOUT THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
INFRASTRUCTURE OR- SEVEN. SEVEN
MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR STDS.
MS GIVENS MAY BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THIS. SORRY SO WE DID
RECEIVE SEVEN MILLION ACTION
HOURS FOR A CD AND TWO MILLION
IS ONGOING AND WE ADDED THAT TO
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE DOLLARS
AGO AT TWO THIRTY THREE LOCAL
CULTURE STICKS AND THAT DOES
PAPER TIES OR SO IS TO
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS SO THEY'RE
LOCALIST PRIOR TO THAT IN THE
TWO MILLION ONE POINT SIX SEVEN
SO WE HAVE THREE POINT SIX
SEVEN TO PUT OUT THERE ON THE
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION WENT TO
TWENTY THREE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. AND 50% OF GO
TO- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WELL AND THAT IS
A MORE BROAD ARRAY TO THAT
RISING UP THAT MIGHT UP CITY
HALL. THANK YOU IN I'M- YES I
JUST ANSWERING TERM MEMBERS CUT
MY ESSENTIAL. PUT A FINER POINT
ON THAT THAT SEVEN MILLION
AGAIN THE TWO I'M GOING THE
OTHERS TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE DATE- IT'S BROADER THAN
JUST SYPHILIS AND IT DOES GO TO
MORE THINGS AND IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE IT'S TESTING AND
TREATMENT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DOLLARS THERE TO DO. TO DO THAT
THE CASE MANAGEMENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE SO THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. NO AND I
THINK THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF
IT WHICH IS THAT THERE'S THIS
NEED FOR HIGH TOUCH WHEN IT'S
REQUIRING- TREATMENTS TO
PATIENTS WHO DON'T. ALWAYS SEEK
HELP AND SO- DO APPRECIATE THIS
PROPOSAL BUT AT THIS TIME WE
WILL HOLD ISSUES SEVENTEEN OPEN.
THANK YOU. JUST IN TERMS OF THE
AGENDA WE WILL MOVE BACK TO
ISSUE ELEVEN AND I UNDERSTAND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLOIA IT WILL
NOT BE HERE BUT THANK HIM FOR
SPONSORING THE NEXT SIX
PROPOSALS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME CIVIC
HESTIA AND I'M WITH ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH- WE CHAMPION
PROMOTE A QUALITY SEXUALLY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL. OUR STD PREVENTION CENTER
WORKS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE SB CONTROL BRANCH A
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
PROVIDERS TO IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES AN STD PREVENTION AND
CASE MANAGEMENT. UP FIRST OFFER
HERE THINK YOU AS LEADERS IN
OUR STATE FOR TAKING NOTICE AND
TAKING INITIAL STEPS TO ADDRESS
THE STD PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
LAST YEAR STATE BUDGET AS I
HEARD YOU MENTION INCLUDED
SEVEN MILLION ON GOING FOR
THREE YEARS FIVE MILLION OF
WHICH IS SUBJECT TO THIS. YOU
KNOW REVISION DATE OF THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT THE AMOUNT IS NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH TO PROPERLY DEAL
WITH THIS EPIDEMIC. IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE RATES FOR
CHLAMYDIA GONORRHEA AND
SYPHILIS TO HAVE SINCE THEN
HAVE HIT RECORD HIGHS THREE
TIMES AND WE'VE TEETERED IN
RANKING BETWEEN FIRST SECOND
AND THIRD IN THE NATION. FOR
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF CASES FOR
THOSE THREE DISEASES. MORE THAN
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CASES WERE REPORTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S A JUMP
OF 40% SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
THIS IS NO LONGER AN UP AND
MAKE IT'S A CRISIS SITUATION
THAT IMPACTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE. POPULATIONS IN OUR
STATE AND THE DISPARITIES
PERSIST IN TERMS OF WHAT
CALIFORNIANS AFFECT THE MY- HI.
IN THE STATE HI S. T. NUMBERS.
FRESNO OKAY AND CURRENT. IS THE
BAY AREA. DECEMBER NINETEEN NO
AN ORANGE COUNTY'S LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MIDDLE SEEN NO AND
SACRAMENTO THOSE ON THE HOT
SPOT. ON THE STD RATES ARE
FOUND THE MOST THE HIGHEST
RATES ARE FOUND AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTY
MEN WHO HAVE SEX WITH MEN. AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN TERMS
OF DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IS SPENT
ANNUALLY STATEWIDE ON HEALTH
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH STDS. THE
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED
LAST YEAR OUR S. HAVE STILL NOT
BEEN DISTRIBUTED OUT SO WE'RE
WAITING TO SEE WHAT THE IMPACT
WILL BE IN THE OUTCOMES ON THE
GROUND- BUT WE DO COMMENDED PH
IS. EXCELLENT JOB AND- THE
PROCESS THEY CREATED TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS- ACROSS THE
STATE IN A TRANSPARENT MANNER
THAT INCORPORATED FEEDBACK FROM
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS- WHILE
PUBLIC COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AE HAPPY TO
RECEIVE THE FIND THE SPENDING
BOOST. BECAUSE IT'S NOT ONGOING
FUNDING NINE CAN HIRE NEW FULL
TIME STAFF. AND ARE COMING UP
WITH CREATIVE WAYS TO MAXIMIZE
THESE NEW FUNDS- A FEW COUNTIES
WILL BE RECEIVING ENOUGH FUNDS
TO JUST BOLSTER EXISTING
PROGRAMS LIKE. MOBILE CLINIC
THAT CONDUCT RAPID STD TESTING
CLINIC TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
FOR TEENS IN RURAL AREAS. ONE
LOCAL HOW JURISDICTION WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HIRE PART
TIME STAFF FOR THAT WILL BE
PLACED AT A COMMUNITY NICK THAT
SEES HIGH RATES OF STDS. TO
FOLLOW UP WITH PATIENTS THAT
TEST POSITIVE. AND SO WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS TO COMMITTED
CAN REDEEM THAT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALREADY ALLOCATED.
CONTINUE TO DISTRIBUTE THESE
FUNDS TO LOCAL HEALTH
RESTRICTIONS AND COMMITTEE
ORGANIZATIONS IN OP PRIORITY
TARGET YES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU PUBLIC AND ON ISSUE ELEVEN.
READ MORE NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION STRONG
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT THAT BUILDS
ON THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU ALL
DID LAST YEAR GETTING US SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO THE STD
PREVENTION CONTROL BRANCH I'M
CLEARLY SEVEN MILLION IS GREAT
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH AND THIS WILL
HELP US GET EVEN. FURTHER ALONG
IN OUR- EFFORTS AGAINST
HAPPENED ABOUT THANK YOU. I AM
GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KAREN EVANS
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
AMERICA AND SUPPORTS GIVE ME
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KIMBERLY
ROBINSON WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS IN SUPPORT. WESLEY
SEVERAL WITH GLIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. COURTNEY MAHER PEARSON
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT YOU. COULD POLLS FOR
FROM A PILLAR HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. JERRY
HADDEN ON THIS WITH THE LOSS
AND IT'S ALL DUE TO CENTER IN
SUPPORT. SIR HUTCHINSON WITHOUT
PROVIDING GIRLS IN SUPPORT.
JENNA HE WOULD AT THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HERE IN SUPPORT. LIBBY GOT
THREE MINUTES YOU KNOW COUNTY
AIDS VIRAL HEPATITIS NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SAVANNAH
O'NEILL FROM THE NATIONAL
HERMAN ACTION COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. REGULAR JONES
ON BEHALF OF THE HIV EDUCATION
PREVENTION PROJECT ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DALLAS BLANCHARD FRESNO NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ROB LINDSAY ON BEHALF
OF HAVE BACK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN WE BE MEMBER HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE'RE FINALIZING OUR POSITIONS
ON ALL OF THESE- ACCOMPANYING
LEGISLATION PIECES OF
LEGISLATION SO WE LOOK FOR TO
REPORTING BACK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN HER AGAIN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. I WILL- JUST TAKE
A MOMENT TO. THANK ANDREA
MARGOLIS WHO ALWAYS RIGHTS- OUR
AGENDA AS WELL BUT I THINK
PARTICULARLY HAS HELPED ME TO
BE EDUCATED ON STDS. AND AS WE
LOOK AT A 40% INCREASE SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE
FEDERAL FUNDING IS DOWN 40% IN
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS. AND SO
THE STATE IS DOING. OUR JOB TO
HELP. BUT THERE IS MUCH MORE WE
NEED TO DO BECAUSE OF THE-
ACTIONS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
IT IS AWFULLY CONCERNING THOUGH
WHEN TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND WOMEN
ACROSS THE U. S. EACH YEAR ARE
BECOMING INFERTILE DUE TO THESE
STDS AND DOES REQUIRE OUR
ATTENTION. WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE ELEVEN OPEN AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS JENNA HE WOULD AYE AND
WHAT THE NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION- WERE A
ADVOCACY AND CAPACITY BUILDING-
INNOVATION. IT'S TURNING INTO
BECAUSE THE ONES. ALL THE THREE
SYRINGE ACCESS PROGRAMS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- AND I WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
INVESTMENT OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
TO SUPPORT STAFF ANSWERING
SERVICES PROGRAMS. OF THESE
FUNDS WILL ALLOW FOR CRITICAL
EXPANSION OF SERVICES FOR HARM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. TO MAGNUM
MAXIMIZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE FAR. INCREASE THIS SUPPLY
CO. IS NEEDED THAT'S WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN INCREASE OF FIVE
BILLION PER YEAR I'M GOING OF
FOR THE STATE. SUPPLY HOUSE.
THE PLIGHT DURING UP FURNISHES
HERMAN XIN SUPPLIES TO INCH
SERVICE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE PUTTING SYRINGES IN A LOT
OWN AN OLD STRIPPED. THEIR
SUPPLIES INJECTION PERCENT
THESE SAY IT BUYS. DISTRICT.
DIRECT PEOPLE WHO. MISSION OF A
B. H. SO V. SKIN AND SAW TISSUE
IN ENTER OVER DEATH SINCE TWO
FIFTEEN ON THE CLEARING HOUSE
PHONE WAS DEVELOP THERE'S BEEN
AN ADDITIONAL US THIRTEEN NEW
PROGRAM STARTED IN TEN NEW
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
THERE WILL BE AT LEAST SIX NEW
PROGRAM CERTIFIED THIS YEAR AND
WE EXPECT THAT THE TO GROW IN
IN UPCOMING YEARS AS WELL. THE
GROWTH IN NEW PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
TO THE CURRENT FUND IN THE
SUPPLY BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
PROGRAMS HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE
IN THE MAIN. SUPPLY OVER FIFTY
PERCENT- THERE ARE IN HARMONY
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS HERE
TODAY FROM ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
MENDOCINO. SAN FRANCISCO ONE
FRESNO COUNTIES WHO CAN TELL
YOU FIRST HAND HOW THEY HAVE
HAD TO RATION SUPPLIES BECAUSE
THE CLEARING HOUSE BUDGET DOES
NOT MEET NEED IN THIS. SEVERAL
STERILE SYRINGES PER RIGHT
BRENT. ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE HIV AND H. CV
PREVENTION TOOLS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY PRODUCTION PROGRAMS
PROVIDE LOW BARRIER RESOURCES
TO PEOPLE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
HARD TO REACH. MONEY INVESTED
IN THESE PROGRAMS MEANS SAVINGS
AND AVERTED H. I. G. H. C. VI
N. AT TD CASE- AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. A REDUCTION AN
OVERDOSE DEATHS. YOU'RE NOT
LAST YEAR AND STAFF FOR THESE
PROGRAMS ILLUSTRATES THAT YOU
VALUE HARM REDUCTION. EVENT
IT'S AGAIN FOR THIS FUNDING
HOWEVER THESE CAN BE USED FOR
SUPPLIES INVESTING IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE SUPPLY FUND WILL
ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO EXPERIENCE
THE FULL BENEFITS OF THE-
MILLION ALREADY INVESTED IN
THESE ISN'T SERVICES. THANK YOU
WAS PUBLIC COMPANIES TO TWELVE.
YES HELLO ADELE SPONSOR WITH
THE PRESIDENT ELECT SHANGE- THE
LAST YEAR WE DID ONE POINT. ONE
MILLION FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
SYRINGES THIS YEAR WE'RE ON
TRACK TO DO ONE POINT TWO
MILLION. WE'RE AT THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO RATION WHETHER
WE GIVE SYRINGES OR NALOXONE.
THANK YOU SIR. REVEL IN THE
FROM HER PACK IN STRONG SUPPORT
YOU. MAKAYLA JONES ALSO FROM
HAVE BACK SO JUST A COUPLE
NOTES ABOUT THIS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR INVESTING ALL THIS
MONEY BUT AS WE TALKED ABOUT
ALL THROUGHOUT THE DAY THIS
DEMAND CONSTANTLY INCREASING
OUR PROGRAMS ARE STRIPPED THEN
WE KNOW THERE'S ALREADY CRACKS
IN THE SYSTEM WHEN OUR PROGRAMS
ARE STRETCHED EVEN. IN DUE TO
PASS THE UNLIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAN WHAT WE KNOW
THESE CRACKS. AND WE ARE
REACHING THE OUT RISK POPULAR
FOLK ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
GETTING THESE DIFFERENT
DISEASES AND THEN CONTINUING TO
SPREAD THEIR- COUNTIES WE WORK
IN ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES. IN THIS NUMBER LEE
ROB. FIND OPENING WOULD ALLOW
US TO CREATE. MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE SUPPLY
AS WELL AS MORE. WHO WE CAN GET
IN THERE TO HELP THESE FOLKS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
LET ME GET THREE MENDOCINO
COUNTY AIDS VIRAL HEPATITIS
NETWORK AND JUST IN THE
200-018-2000 NINETEEN YEAR. WE
HAD AN INCREASE OF- NEED FOR
SYRINGES OF FIFTY PERCENT. IT
WAS THE MOST DRAMATIC. INCREASE
WE'VE HAD IN OUR TWENTY YEARS
OF SERVICE. IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GIVEN MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
MA'AM CRIPPLED PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL AGAIN JUST EMPHASIZE
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS HIV AND HEPATITIS C.
SO VERY IMPORTANT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE DID THANK YOU. YOU
COURTNEY MAHER PEARSON THEY'RE
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT YOU. WESLEY SERVER WITH
GLADDEN SUPPORT ARE HOMOSEXUAL
TEAM IN SAN FRANCISCO IS SEEING
A DEMAND NOT JUST FOR SYRINGE
ACCESS BUT WE ALSO IN YOUR SAY
SMOKING SUPPLIES AS WELL AND
THIS WOULD. INCREASE OUR BE
REACH THOSE RELATIONS VENN
MARK. THANK YOU. SIR CHECK IN
ON THE RESULTS WHICH IS
INSTRUCTS. SIR TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. SEVEN
O'NEILL AT THE NATIONAL HERMAN
ACTION COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE SALES ONE OF THE
PEOPLE HELPING GROW THESE
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE AFTER
WORKING IN THEM FOR TWELVE
YEARS AND DIRECT SERVICE THERE
ARE SO MANY MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY COMMITTED TO. ADDRESSING
HEALTH DISPARITIES FOR PEOPLE
USE DRUGS AND THE OPIOID CRISIS
AND NEED MORE SUPPLIES IN ORDER
TO CONNECT. SO AT OF WORKING
WITH AND ALLOW THAT GROWTH TO
RELEASE THE- THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING FOR THE WHAT COMMON
BRING IT UP TO THE SUB LEVEL-
YOU KNOW I. I DO SEE DALLAS
BLANCHARD WHO'S HERE AND THE
SOMEONE WHO I VOLUNTEERED WITH.
IN FRESNO WITH DOCTOR LASHER
HAD A PROGRAM. OPTION AND TO
SEE THE BENEFIT. MIGHT QUESTION
FOR YOU IS ONE THAT THEN GETS
TECHNICAL REGARDING. ONGOING
VERSES ONE TIME FUND. I DO
NOTICE THAT THE FUN WE HAD FOR
LAST YEAR. FIRE THREE MORE
YEARS AND SO. WHEN YOU DON'T
DANCE NOW BUT WE WANT. MATCHING
WHAT WAS DONE FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS IS ADEQUATE FOR THE
CLEARING HOUSE TO AT LEAST GET
US THROUGH THE NEXT YEAR. I'M
ONLY BECAUSE ONGOING IS MORE
CHALLENGING FOR US AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND SO WE JUST WANT
TO ENGAGE INTO THAT
CONVERSATION OUTSIDE OF THIS
COULD. I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT IT. WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE TWELVE OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THIRTY. THANK
YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON CRIPPLES
FOR- SAYS HE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS A PELE
HEALTH- THE NEXT PROPOSAL FROM
THE IN THE EPIDEMICS COALITION
WOULD PROVIDE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME- FOR THE STATE
TO DEVELOP ACROSS DEPARTMENTAL
STRATEGY OR MASTER PLAN TO ADD
AN HIV HEPATITIS C. AN S. T. D.
EPIDEMIC CALIPHS YEAH AS NOW
CITIES ACROSS TREAT ARE SCALING
UP EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THESE
EPIDEMIC. AND FORTY A LOT WHY
THEN AIDS OTHERS NEEDED MORE
THAN TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO IMPLEMENT THE
INITIATIVE OF AND CASES HAVE
PRETTY THE I AND THE PERCENT
BLAST THE STATE FOR THOSE ON.
IT'S UP. SAN FRANCISCO LAW A
SIMILAR IN ME FIFTEEN AND LAST
YEAR NEW HIV CASES FELL BELOW
TWO HUNDRED FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER PUT IN THE CITY ON TRACK
TO BECOME THE FIRST IN THE
COUNTRY TO GET TO ZERO NEW
CASES OF IT SB. THE
OVERWHELMING SUCCESS OF THESE
IT DOES PROVIDE EVIDENCE TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIC PLAN
COUPLED WITH POLITICAL WELL AN
ADEQUATE RESOURCES CAN DRIVE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE
TIDE THESE EPIDEMIC. TO MENTION
THE SIMILAR. UNDER WAY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. PRESS NOT ONLY A
CHEVY ABOUT HEPATITIS C. IN
STDS AS WELL. LAST YEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED A PLANT
AND THE HIV EPIDEMIC BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND THIS YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WILL RELEASE. THE
FIRST EVER FAT **** TO THE
ACTION AND ALONG WITH UPDATE
THE NATIONAL HEPATITIS ACT PLAN.
THAT CAN. ARE COMPLETE IS YET
TO LAUNCH A SIMILAR INITIATIVE
AND THESE EPIDEMICS CONTINUE TO
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL. AT THIRD
CD CASE ARE BIASED LEVEL IN
YEARS. THE STATE'S HOW DOUBLE
DIGIT INCREASES. OF KAY UNTIL
SEPT. TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OVER FOUR
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA OVER. THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING WITH
HEPATITIS C. IN. INCREASE 50% A
YOUNG BOY FROM. INTO TO SIX.
AND WHILE. THE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARD THE REDUCING YOU CASE HM.
LAST PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE TO
REDUCE THE CASE AND CAN USE OF
COLOR WHO REMAIN HARDEST HIT BY
THE EPIDEMIC. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO RESUME ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE AND DEVELOP AN
AGGRESSIVE STRATEGY TO AND
THESE EPIDEMICS THIS PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE HHS IN THE OFFICE
OF AIDS WITH THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO BRING TOGETHER
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS IN KEY
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP
EFFECTIVE STATE WIDE STREET IT
TO ADDRESS HIV THE TENNESSEAN
STD IS. THAT NOT YOUR INITIAL
WITHIN PH OR THE OFFICE OF AIDS
OVER THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS RELY
ON MEDI CAL PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
SERRATED REMAIN AMONG THE
POPULATION PHONE TO THESE
CONDITIONS NURSES MUST PROVIDE
YOU. WITH THE XIN. THANK YOU
THE STATE. BACK TO MASTER CRIER
WERE WILL BJ COORDINATION
ACROSS. OUR MEN'S THE SERB
PEOPLE LIVING AND VULNERABLE TO
THE CAN INCLUDING SEE PA H. C.
S. C. C. R. AMONG OTHERS
GREATER COORDINATION ACROSS
STATE DEPARTMENTS WILL REDUCE
PROGRAM COMPLEX PROVIDE A
GREATER POOL OF AVAILABLE IN
ANTENATAL PUBLIC SERVICES TO
REACH PATIENTS THAT OTHERWISE
MASS REAL PROGRESS POSSIBLE IN
WRITING TINA PLACES AROUND THE
WORLD. WE WILL NOT BE
SUCCESSFUL UNTIL WE HAVE
POLITICAL WILL AND THE STRATEGY
TO MAKE AND IN THE AND IN THESE
UP TO THEM THAT'S A REALITY
THANK YOU YOU. THE COMMENT ON
THE THIRTEEN. MICHELLE GIVEN TO
CHECK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEVEN O'NEILL FROM THE HERMAN
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
COURTNEY MULHER PEARSON SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. WOULD BE GOT THREE IN
THE SCENE- AIDS VIRAL HEPATITIS
NETWORK- I'VE WATCHED THE
CONVERGENCE OF THESE-
CONDITIONS OVER THE LAST THIRTY
THREE YEARS WORKING IN THIS
FIELD AND IT'S TIME THAT WE
TAKE MAJOR STEPS. IN
COORDINATING OUR EFFORTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I ANGER MAYES
FAILURE OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
IF YOU'RE- JENNA HEY WOULD
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JERRY HAD NON
THERE'S LESS AND JUST TOLD ME
TO CENTER IN SUPPORT. MAR NEEDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION A SUPPORT.
WESLEY SERVER WITH GLIDE SPORT.
KEN ROBINSON WITH BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS AND SUPPORT YOU
CAN. AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES YOUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. CAN BROOK SOME
OF THE ANGELES BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. SO VACANCY WITH
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT. DALLAS
BLANCHARD FOR THE NEEDLE
EXCHANGE- IN STRONG SUPPORT. I
KAYLA JONES HIV EDUCATION
PREVENTION PROJECT ON THE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
LEGISLATION BUT I MIGHT BE A CO
AUTHOR ON A MASTER PLAN
BUILDING THE SIMILAR AREA AND
SO- I DID WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FORTY SEVEN
SECOND PARAGRAPH THERE'S A
SENTENCE THAT SAYS
UNFORTUNATELY HIV HABSI AND S.
T. EYES HAVE NOT BEEN
ADEQUATELY PRIORITIZED AND CAL
AIM TO ENSURE MEDI CAL AND
ROLLED EASE OUR PROP AT
SCREENED CAN YOU EXTRAPOLATE ON
THAT LITTLE BIT AND HELP TO
EXPLAIN WE HAVE NOT HAD
HEARINGS REGARDING CAL AIM AT.
WELL AS THE LA CAME OUT WITH-
REPORT ON CALLIN TODAY BUT JUST
YEAH I WANTED YOU TO ADD A
LITTLE MORE TO THAT IF YOU
COULD YEP YES SO I'M CERTAINLY
NOT THE EXPERT ON CALLAHAM SO
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE VARIOUS
WORK GROUPS THAT BEEN WORKING
ON CAL AIM. I THINK THE POINT
OF THAT COMMENT IS JUST
RECOGNIZING THAT IF THE DAY AS
A STRIP CHECK LIVE TO RUSTY
DEMI THERE WOULD BE ST
INITIATIVE WILL WITH CAL AIM
MISSING OUT CONTROL THE FOLKS
HAVE ACCESS TO TESTING AND
TREATMENT. I AN EXIT POLL. IN A
ANSWER I TALKS ABOUT VALUE
BASED IN SHOULD'VE SO AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE DO NOT
IN THE KERN CALENDAR. IN TERMS
OF. PROVIDING VALUE BASED
PAYMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE BARELY SUPPRESSED FOR
MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS- RECEIVE
TESTING AND SO. I THINK THE
IDEA IS THAT IF THE STATE HAD
ROLLED FORWARD. AS YOU KNOW HAD
MORE STRATEGIC FOCUS ON THESE
INITIATIVES THAT CAL AIM- WOULD
HAVE MORE OF A FOCUS ON MAKING
SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE. ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THEY NEED- I MASS
THAT WE- BRING THAT UP WHEN WE
HAVE THE HEARING TO SEE- AND
JUST TO. BE CLEAR FOR THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING COLIN IS ALSO
KNOWN AS MEDICAL HEALTHIER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL- IT IS.
ACRONYM IS SUPPOSED TO STAND
FOR ADVANCING IN INNOVATING
WITHIN MEDI CAL. AND THE GOAL
IN MANY PARTS IS TO. LEAVE
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF SILENCE
WE HAVE BEEN HELD. THIS
INTEGRATION AND SO- I THINK
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE TIME FOR US
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WHEN
CALLING COMES UP. WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE THIRTEEN OPEN
IN THE BOND ISSUE FORTY. AND
I'M IS THIS A PRESENT ON
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN DIEM IN A
WAIT BETWEEN HER GO STRAIGHT
THROUGH IF YOU CAN ONLY SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR.
OF THE INDIVIDUAL ISSUES SCRIPT
SO THANK YOU TO THAT- COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING THIS REQUEST TODAY
MY NAME IS COURTNEY MULHER
PEARSON WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION. ALSO CO CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIV ALLIANCE
AND WITH IT- AND THE EPIDEMICS-
ADVOCACY COALITION. SO WE'VE
WANTED TO START BY THANKING-
THE STATE FOR THE INVESTMENT OF
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- IN HIV
PREVENTION DOLLARS LAST YEAR-
THAT WAS PART OF OUR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR REQUESTS THAT WE
MADE- FOR ONGOING FUNDING. SO
I'M BACK FOR MORE AND ASKING
FOR AGAIN FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AN ON GOING FUNDING AND
ALSO WOULD LOVE TO. CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION AROUND THAT-
THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
CALLED TIMELIMIT ON THAT THAT
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND DATE
FOR THE- LAST YEAR'S MONEY AND
IF THAT IS OPEN TO. DISCUSSION
FOR CONVERTING THAT TO. ON
BRING FUNDING IS WE WOULD LOVE
TO BE. PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. I'M SORRY HEARD A
COUPLE TIMES TODAY. I TV
DOESN'T BRING YEAH I'M- IN. SO
WE I AM WE SAW THIRTIES.
MILLION DOLLARS CUT FROM HIV
PREVENTION. PORTFOLIO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE- AND WE'VE BEEN
STEADILY KIND OF CHIPPING AWAY
AND TRYING TO RE INVESTOR YOU
ALL HAVE BEEN THANK YOU- SINCE
THEN AND- AND WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE A RETURN. I'M NOT. MEN SO
FROM ANY FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BESIDE A ROUGHLY
PERCENT DECREASE. AT NEW HIV
INFECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT PROGRESS HAS
BEEN UNEVEN- AND THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES UP
IT'S- DIFFICULT AMONG BLACK AND
WHITE NEXT COMMUNITY. TO BE. I
AM BACK. THE H. EPIDEMIC I'M-
RAN. IN A- CHEN IN CALIFORNIA
DOES AGAIN SHOW THAT ASSESSMENT
WORKS. ARE BIG. SEE THAT THE
NEW ATV I'M- THE CALL THANK.
I'M BUT THAT HEALTH INEQUITIES
ARE CONTINUING TO INCREASE OF
BETWEEN. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NUMBER. CASE TO CREATE.
DECREASED I'M AT SPEND THE
PERCENT AMONG- WHITE
POPULATION. AND ONLY FOR ANIMAL
NOW AND- PRIEST TO PRESS AMONG
POP. I'M THE IT USING A RISK
ARE THERE NEED TO AND EXPAND
EACH PER POT F. FOR THIS
POPULAR WE DO REALLY IT THE
EFFORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS
THAT WE GOT STE YEAR WERE.
APPARENTLY AND THEY- AGAIN WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER RECEIVED
SIXTY OVER SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND REQUEST- FOR
FUNDING FOR OVER AND I THINK
THEY ARE ONLY ALLOCATING ABOUT
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION SO THE
NEED IS THERE- THEY'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB WITH THE DOLLARS THEY
GET AND MAKING SURE THAT IT
GOES THE POPULAR AND
COMMUNITIES ARE AT ME NEED BUT
WE MORE DOLLARS ESSENTIALLY- SO
GAIN. PROPOSED SINGLE PROVIDE
GRANTS TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EVIDENCE
BASED AND STRENGTH A STRATEGIES
THAT INCLUDE BIOMEDICAL AND
STRUCTURAL INTERVENTIONS. AND A
AND- URGE THAT THESE
INTERVENTIONS ARE TAILORED TO
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE'S MOST
UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS-
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN A
LOT NEXT INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH AND MOST AT RISK FOR HIV.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FOURTEEN. WESLEY SEVERAL WITH
GLIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT. JERRY
HAD NONE THE LESS AND JUST AS
WE T. CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. KAREN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT HUMAN. TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. WE KILL JONES HIV
EDUCATION PREVENTION PROJECT
ABOUT ME TO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT I ALSO JUST WANT TO
MAKE A QUICK COMMENT STATING
THAT WE CANNOT PROP PROVIDE
ACCESS TO THESE FOLKS HAVE WE
OURSELVES ARE HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE RESOURCES AND I KNOW THAT
OUR COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVICE
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK AFRICAN
AMERICAN SAID 6% THAT WE NEED
TO THEIR THAT LARGEST
POPULATION ARE MOST AT RISK AND
IF WE CANNOT PROVIDE TESTERS TO
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE WE HAVE TO HAVE THOSE
FUNDS OF WE CANNOT PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE TO THEM THEN THEY DON'T
KNOW THEIR STATUS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT INCREASE
OVER TIME SO THIS FIVE WOULD
MEAN A LOT PACIFIC. FOR MY NO
FOR ORGAN. X. ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT THE HUMAN. CHAU GIVEN
SO THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY ANGER
MAYES FAILURE OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. CORRECT POLLS FOR FROM
A PALEY HEALTH AND SUPPORT SIR.
RAND MORE NUMBER HAVE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
GEN HEY WOULD WITH THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROBINSON WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS IN SUPPORT.
I CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE BAKER THREE MINUTES YOU
KNOW COUNTY AIDS VIRAL
HEPATITIS NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- THIS TIME WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE FOURTEEN OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU. SO AGAIN THE AND THAT BUT
I MIX COALITION WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THE BUDGET AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE THE IT IS STRUCK
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. IMPROPER
OUT ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM FROM
5100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL SIX HUNDRED AT THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IN ORDER
TO BETTER ALIGN WITH THE NEW
STATES CITIES VIRGIL'S A INCOME
ALL FOR THE- AND THE- AS YOU
HEARD MENTOR. THAT ADAM STATE
EIGHT APP RE RE. WHERE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THOSE REBATES CAN
BE USED TO PAY FOR THIS
INCREASE- SO IT CALIFORNIA'S
EIGHT OUT PROGRAM AND PROP UP
ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR EFFORTS
TO AN H. A. B. ADEPT AT AMICK-
EIGHT OUT PROVIDES FINANCIAL.
MEDICATIONS HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS AND MEDICAL OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS LIVING WITH. HIV AND
COVERS THIRTY ONE OR PROVIDES.
A SERVICE THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR. AND THEN
PROP UP WHICH IS A NEWER
PROGRAM. THEY EAT BALL AT AM AT
AND ISSUED AS WELL YEARS AGO.
COVERS PROP AND PEPPER LATE AND
MEDICAL EXPENSES AND MEDICATION
COSTS FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
WHO ARE AT RISK OF ACQUIRING H.
A. B. AND SINCE IT LAUNCHED
INTO TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
PROGRAM IS ALREADY HELPED OVER
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
ACCESS PREP AND PAP. ATV
PREVENTION IT UP AS A THREE
FORTY B. ENTITY AND AS SUCH
COLLECTS A MANDATORY REBATE-
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE
MEDICATIONS ARE PRESCRIPTIONS
COVERED- IT ALSO RECEIVES
VOLUNTARY SUPPLEMENTAL REBATES-
ABOVE AND BEYOND THREE FORTY P.
AND THOSE ARE NEGOTIATED A
FEDERAL AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WITH THE OTHER EIGHT OUT
PROGRAMS THROUGH THAT I'M EIGHT
OUT CRISIS TASK FORCE ON THESE
REBATES ARE REALLY DRIVING- THE
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW SO THESE
REBATES COUNT FOR ROUGHLY THREE
QUARTERS OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM'S BUDGET. I'M TWENTY
FIFTEEN M. WE WERE SUCCESSFUL
ARE YOU ARE- KIND ENOUGH TO
INCREASE ELIGIBILITY LEVEL TO
FIVE HUNDRED PERCENT. FROM A
FLAT FIFTY THOUSAND AND THAT
WAS AGAIN REFLECTING THE NEED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THE
INCREASING COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WE'RE BACK
BECAUSE THOSE COSTS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. I AM VERY SUPPORT
FEATHER THE INCREASE. THE
LEVELS FOR COVER CALIFORNIA AND
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE SAME
HAPPEN IN THIS PROGRAM. WE
ESTIMATE THAT THAT CHANGE WITH
A VERY SMALL IMPACT- ON THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL SERVERS SO
IT'S NOT A HUGE COST BUT FOR
THE FOLKS THAT WOULD NOW BE
ELIGIBLE IT'S I'M HUGELY
IMPACTFUL- AND WOULD REALLY-
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE SO. WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL- YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ISSUE FIFTEEN.
PROPOSED FOR MADE KELLY HELP
AND SUPPORT SIR. JERRY AT NINE
THIS LOZENGES LGBT CENTER IN
SUPPORT YOU. WHAT'S THE SEVERAL
GLIDE IN SUPPORT. JENNA HE
WOULD AT THE NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ROB HAVE BACK IN SUPPORT YOU.
DALLAS BLANCHARD PRESENT NEEDLE
EXCHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THREAD O'NEILL FROM THE
NATIONAL HERMAN ACTION CAUTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. WE GOT THREE
MENDOCINO COUNTY AIDS VIRAL
HEPATITIS NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TERRY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MICHELLE GIVEN TO
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM SEEING
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
BRING IT UP TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE- YOU SAID THERE WERE
NEGLIGIBLE COST I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD EXTRAPOLATE A LITTLE
BIT- SINCE. THEY ARE COVERED BY
A REBATES- IS IT WHAT WOULD THE
COST BE TO THE STATE IF
ANYTHING HOWEVER IT AT
SUBMITTED A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE REQUEST TO GET THE
COSTS BUT WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED-
AN ANSWER YET SO I CAN GET
BACK. YOU WHEN WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. SENSUALLY REBATE
FUNDS CAN BE USED TO COVER
THAT- INCREASE CLIENT LOAD SO.
IT SHOULDN'T NEED ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND TO COVER THIS
INCREASE. FROM THE BUDGET
NEUTRAL THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
FOR THE COMMITTEE AS- BUT WE
DID MAKE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
LAST YEAR TO WORK ON
AFFORDABILITY WITH SUBSIDIES UP
26100% IN THIS. SEEMS
CONSISTENT WITH. KURT I WOULD
JUST WANT TO. INSURE AND WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK WHEN
YOU GET IT. I'M WITH THAT WILL
HOLD ISSUE FIFTEEN OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIXTEEN. HI
I'M ENTIRELY ON THE DIRECTOR OF
STATE HEALTH CARE POLICY THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION.
AND I'D LIKE TO FIRST THOUGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN ECHO
THE THANKS FOR THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED LAST YEAR FOR
H. CV OR HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION FUNDS. ON WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
CONVERTING THOSE FUNDS TO
ONGOING FUNDS ON THIS YEAR.
YOUR TO ASPER FIFTY IN DOLLARS
FOR HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION
SERVICES INCLUDING HEALTH
NAVIGATION LINK LINKAGE
SERVICES WITH A FOCUS ON PEOPLE
WHO USE DRUGS. CALIFORNIA'S
SERIOUSLY DURING UNDER INVESTED
IN- HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION
RIGHT NOW EVEN WITH THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM LST YEAR WE HAD
JUST BARELY OVER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO SUPPORT
ALL OF THESE PREVENTION
SERVICES THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH CULTURALLY COMPETENT. AND
QUALITY CARE HEALTH CARE. I'M
CURRENTLY A WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
HEPATITIS C. OVER HALF OF THEM
DON'T EVEN KNOW THEIR STATUS
RIGHT NOW THE RATE OF HCV
INFECTION AMONG YOUTH
PARTICULARLY THOSE UNDER THIRTY
IS GROWING AT AN ALARMING RATE
IT'S DRIVEN BY THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC ALSO INJECTIONS. OF
HEROIN AND OTHER DRUG USE
BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN A TOTAL OF.
1-300-060-0832 EIGHTY CD CASES
WERE REPORTED AMONG PEOPLE AGED
FIFTY TWENTY NOT 50% INCREASE.
UNINTENTIONALLY WE HAD
380-006-0050 SIX NEWLY REPORTED
CASES OF HEPATITIS C. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
RANKED. FIRST IN STATES THAT
REPORTED THEIR HEPATITIS C.
SURVEILLANCE THAT YEAR. SO JUST
TODAY THE U. S. PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TASK FORCE ISSUED ITS
FINAL RECOMMENDATION OF A GRADE
B. FOR UNIVERSAL HCV TESTING
FOR ALL ADULTS AGED EIGHTEEN
THROUGH SEVENTY NINE. AND THEY
BASE OF THEIR EVIDENCE IN PART
THAT HCV IS ASSOCIATED WITH
MORE DEATH FROM THE TOP THE
OTHER TOP SIXTY REPORTABLE
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. AND ALSO
THAT UNIVERSAL SCREENING COULD
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NET BENEFIT
IN TERMS OF IMPROVED HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND AVERTED HEALTHCARE
COSTS. THE TASK FORCE ALSO
CITED RESEARCH SUGGESTING THAT
HEALTH CARE SETTING SERVING
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE PEOPLE
THOSE FOR LOW INCOME UNINSURED
OR UNDERSERVED. HAD VERY LOW
RATES OF HCV SCREENING UNDER
THE PREVIOUS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND STATED THAT IMPLEMENTATION
OF A SUCCESSFUL SCREENING MAY
REQUIRE ADDRESSING. VARIOUS
BARRIERS TO SCREENING AND
TREATMENT AND DISEASE AND
DIVERSE POPULATIONS. SO THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR TODAY WOULD BEGIN TO AN
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS
PARTICULARLY FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
USING DRUGS. OUT REGION
PREVENTION SERVICES ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE USING DRUGS WHO
ARE OFTEN DISENFRANCHISED FROM
TRADITIONAL RESOURCES AND
HEALTH CARE NETWORKS AND
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY STIGMA. A
RECENT REPORT BY THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCE ENGINEERING
MEDICINE FOUND THE KEY BARRIER
TO CARE FOR THOSE USING DRUGS
WAS STIGMA AND THAT IT
PREVENTED PEOPLE FROM SEEKING
IN ACCESSING CARE AND ALSO
AFFECTED EFFECTIVE PROVIDER
PATIENT RELATIONSHIPS. RESEARCH
FROM THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
FOR THE STEP STUDY OF LIVER
DISEASES FOUND THAT ADDRESSING
GAPS IN PREVENTION CARE AMONG
YOUTH IS ESSENTIAL TO
ADDRESSING THE HCV EPIDEMIC. SO
ARE PROPOSED INVESTMENT WOULD
ALLOW US TO BILL AND SUCCESSFUL
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS WERE
FUNDED HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT 95% OF
THOSE WHO ARE LINKED TO IN
RETAINING CARE THROUGH THE
PROJECTS WERE ACTUALLY CURED.
SO ON THIS INVESTMENT COULD
SUPPORT BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND
THIRTY PROGRAMS NEW PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS FUND- AS WELL AS
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED FUNDED FOR
FUNDING FOR THE OFFICE OF VIRAL
HEPATITIS PREVENTION AT CITY
PH. ON SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND- AFFECTED MONITORING OF HIV
IN CALIFORNIA. THEY ALSO JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE FACT
THAT WITH THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR- ALLOCATION LAST YEAR WE
DID WANT TO COMMEND. THE CITY
PH IN THE WAY THAT THEY
ALLOCATED THOSE FUNDS WAS VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND HAD A LOT OF
COMMUNITY. INPUT EVEN. THOUGH
THE FABRIC LIMITED AND NOT
NEARLY BUT WE NEED SO WE HAVE
AS YOU KNOW AND THEN PRESS THE
PRESIDENT A CHANCE RIGHT NOW TO
ACTUALLY AND H. CD IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE. SIMPLE AND
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE EIGHT TO
TWELVE WEEKS TREATMENT
PROTOCOLS. THAT PROVIDE CURE
RATES OF 95% ON. TREATING
PEOPLE FOR H. CV CAN IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASES HEALTH
LIFE EXPECTANCY AND IT
DEFINITELY REDUCES OVERALL
HEALTH CARE EXPENDITURES. BUT
IN ORDER TO REACH THOSE
OUTCOMES WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
HAVE THE- ESPECIALLY FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE PREVENTIVE
SERVICES THAT MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO ACCESS. THAT THAT
QUALITY CARE AND TREATMENT.
THANK YOU MA'AM WELL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE SIXTEEN.
YEAH WOULD BE GOT THREE
MENDOCINO COUNTY AIDS VIRAL
HEPATITIS NETWORK AND WHAT'S
FUNNY ABOUT THAT IS THAT WE
HAVE NO DEDICATED- HCV FUNDING
AND ALL THE FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE RECEIVED OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS HAS COME FROM
FOUNDATIONS AND CHICAGO AND NEW
YORK IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
PLACES BUT THERE IS NO
INVESTMENT IN OUR OWN COUNTY
WERE THE ONLY PROVIDER OF-
PREVENT IN EDUCATION OF
OUTREACH SERVICES. CONNECT
PEOPLE TO. AND WE DON'T RECEIVE
A DOLLAR FOR ANY OF THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WESLEY SAID WITH BLOOD
IN STRONG SUPPORT JUST A
COMMENT EACH MONTH ARE HARM
REDUCTION MOBILE OUTREACH TEAM%
IN SAN FRANCISCO- ADMINISTERS
MORE THAN THIRTY SIX HUNDRED H.
I. BEING HCV TESTS- AT FIFTEEN
SITES AROUND SAN FRANCISCO AND
THIS FUNDING REALLY MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE IN BEING ABLE TO
REACH THOSE PEOPLE AND MEET
THAT GROWING NEED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. CRACKPOTS FOR
FROM A PELE HEALTH AND SUPPORT
YOU. JERRY AT NON THIS LESSENS
THE LGBT CENTER IN SUPPORT. MY
ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. A DALLAS
BLANCHARD PRESENT ELECTIONS
PROGRAM IN SUPPORT. MCGILL
JONES HIV EDUCATION PREVENTION
PROJECT FROM THE COUNTY AND
SUPPORT YOU. ERIN EVANS ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. TERRY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT YOU.
SEVEN O'NEILL FROM THE NATIONAL
HERMAN ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. JENNA HEY WOULD A
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT- BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THERE WAS A TWO HUNDRED AND 33%
INCREASE AN ONSITE HCV TESTING
ANSWERING SERVICES PROGRAMS-
AND SO THIS MONEY IS CRITICAL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS
ARE BEING TESTED ARE LINKED TO.
TREATMENT THANK YOU. KIMBERLY
ROBINSON WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING IT UP
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE- AND AT
THIS TIME WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIXTEEN OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION HOUSEKEEPING
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN CARE OF
ISSUE SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN SO
WE ARE NOW ON TO ISSUE IN
NINETEEN. AND AS WE HAVE
HEATHER MYERS MAKE HER WAY UP
TO THE FRONT I ALSO WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO EXPLAIN. WHY
THIS IS ONE OF THE PROPOSALS IN
WHICH I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND THREE WE
AS A LEGISLATURE HAD PASSED A
LAW THAT IF YOU ARE GOING TO
TEACH SEX EDUCATION. YOU ALSO
HAD A TEACHER B. T. Q. OR YOU
COULDN'T TEACH SEX EDUCATION AT
ALL. I WAS FROM ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT DECIDED TO STOP
TEACHING SEX EDUCATION IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE. IT WASN'T UNTIL
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN WE AS A
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH THE YOUTH ACT
A STORK ACHIEVEMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA. THAT ENSURED THAT
WE WOULD. HAVING A
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICALLY
ACCURATE AND AGE APPROPRIATE AS
WELL AS INCLUSIVE EDUCATIONAL
POLICY. SINCE THEN WE HAVE HAD
INCONSISTENT- IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS TO CREATE EDUCATIONAL
DISPARITIES AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
YOU RIGHT NOW. WHILE THIS HAS
BEEN GOING FAIRLY WELL THERE
ARE STILL AREAS IN THE STATE
THAT STILL STRUGGLE WITH THIS
INCLUDING MY DISTRICT AND
STATEWIDE WE'VE SEEN THE RATES
OF STD CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF COUNTIES
LAST YEAR ALONE HAD A 10%
INCREASE AND GONORRHEA. AND
WHILE WE NOTICED THAT CD PH THE
DISPARITIES THAT WERE MOST
AWARE OF ARE THE FACT THAT IT'S
OUR YOUNGER POPULATION IT'S
THOSE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
FOLLOWING THE RECESSION THAT WE
HAD IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
TWELVE THERE WAS A 72% DECREASE
IN THE TOTAL SPENDING ON
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
DELIVERY OF IN CLASSROOM AND
COMMUNITY SEX EDUCATION. BETTER
KNOWN AS TEEN PREGNANCY
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THESE
SIGNIFICANT CUTS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO A NINE FOR
TWENTY NINE PART SPENCE WHO
HAVE BEEN SERVED. OF THE TWO OF
RAM. THE INFORMATION IN IT
CATION GRANT IS THE- GRANT NOT
TO RELY ON FEDERAL FUNDING AND
IS THEREFORE NOT RESTRICTED BY
THE HOSTILE POLICY VIEW. OF THE
CURRENT FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
ALTHOUGH THE PROGRAM WAS
INITIALLY DESIGNED TO FOCUS ON
PREGNANCY PREVENTION IT IS
INVOLVED TO ADDRESS BOTH S. T.
EYES AND HIV PREVENTION AS WELL.
I ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION
ROUNDTABLE. POSE AN ALLOCATION
OF THIRTY THREE AND A HALF
MILLION AND STATE GENERAL FUNDS
FOR THE INFORMATION AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM GRANTS
OPERATED BY THE MATERNAL CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT HEALTH DIVISION
OF THE SEAT. THIS WOULD BE A
ONE TIME APPROPRIATION BUT WITH
THE INTENTION OF THESE FUNDS TO
BE DRAWN DOWN TO FUND TO GRANT
CYCLES AT A MINIMUM INVESTING
IN EDUCATION AT LEAST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. GIVEN THAT SEXUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION IS AN
INVESTMENT IN EQUIPPING
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS NEED TO
MAKE HEALTHY DECISIONS ABOUT
THE RELATIONSHIPS THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR FUTURE AND TO HELP
PREVENT COSTLY PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEM. SO DOES TI SEE IN A-
WELL INTIMATE PART VIOLENCE
ARGUE THAT A SYSTEM INCREASE AN
STI IS AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS WITHIN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. TO
FURTHER DISCUSS THIS THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESTORING THIS
FUNDING I'M HAPPY TO HAVE WITH
ME HEATHER MYERS REGIONAL
REGIONAL PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
MARMONT T. PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. I AND REGIONAL
RENDON ESSENTIAL VALLEY- FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WANTED THE
LARGEST PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN
THE COUNTRY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PP MA'AM REACHED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH EDUCATION INCLUDING. A
54% INCREASE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS RECEIVING AGE
APPROPRIATE SEXUAL HAD HEALTH
EDUCATION. WERE MANTE IS
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE IN AYE
ANY PROGRAM WHICH ASSIST IN OUR
EFFORTS TO SERVE YOUTH IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. MY PROVIDING
THEM WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS NECESSARY TO MAKE
HEALTHY DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
BODIES AND RELATIONSHIPS. I'M
HERE TO SHARE SUCCESS STORY IN
WHICH TO THE I. ANY PROGRAM
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS
THE AND NEEDS OF UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. AND COUNTY WERE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY GAPS EDUCATION
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION CONSULT
WITH THE FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS ADAPT
EVIDENCEBASED INFORM CURRICULA
TO FIT THE POPULATION
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. AND BE
AWARDED ONE OF ONLY NINE I NEED
GRANTS IN THE STATE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS FILM. TO PUT MY
COMMENTS IN PERSPECTIVE I'D
LIKE TO SHARE A STORY WITH YOU.
SEVERAL MONTHS AFTER OUR
INSTRUCTION CONCLUDED AT ONE OF
OUR SITES OUR TEAM IS IN FOR
THAT ONE OF OUR STUDENTS. WHO
IS TOUCHING PROBABLY BY APPEAR
APPEAR THE DID NOT RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION. HE JUST REPORTED
THAT OUR STUDENT CLEARLY
DEFINED THEIR BOUNDARIES.
SOUGHT HELP USING STEPS WE
TAUGHT DURING A CLASS ON
CONSENT. THIS RESULTED IN
REFERRAL FOR BOTH STUDENTS TO
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST FOR FURTHER
SUPPORT. IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THE
NEED FOR ALL USED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION. AS YOU CAN SEE THE
I. ANY GRANT IS A USEFUL TOOL
FOR EDUCATION PROVIDER
SUPPLEMENTING A NOTABLE AMOUNT
OF EDUCATION WORK ITSELF BY
COVERING A PORTION STAFF COSTS.
PROVIDING EDUCATION IS MISSION
DRIVEN WORK THEIR REQUIRES
QUITE A BIT OF TRAINING HIRING
TRAP AND OTHER HEAD. AND IS
CRITICAL TO INVEST IN NINETY
PROGRAM SO CAN SUPPLEMENT THE
COST OF PROVIDING MORE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WITH INCREMENTAL
CREATE THIS TO THE GRANT AMOUNT
IN MAKING GRANTS AVAILABLE THE
I ANY PROGRAM. COULD SERVE A
BROADER YOUTH WAS CURRENTLY
BEING SIR. CREASE ENGAGEMENT BY
HOLDING ADDITIONAL CURE HIM
REUNITES AND PARENTS SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES. INCREASE EFFICIENCY
BY SENDING MORE EDUCATORS TO
RURAL AREAS. SUPPORT PROVIDERS
AND HIRING AN ADDITIONAL
EDUCATOR WHO COULD RICHARD
REDUCE THE GROUP SIZE
ACCOMMODATE MULTIPLE MODES OF
LEARNING AND PROVIDE MORE.
INDIVIDUALIZED INSTRUCTION TO
MEET SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL
PHYSICAL NEEDS. AS A LEADER IN
HEALTH EDUCATION AND A PAST AND
PRESENT BY ANY PARTICIPANT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HELP ENSURE THAT
EVEN MORE EDUCATION PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO APPLY FOR THIS
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY SO THAT I
ANY FUNDED EDUCATION CAN BE
MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE AND MORE
PARTS OF THE STATE. ALL HERE
TODAY TO THAT'S HOW THE STATE
BUDGET CAN BEST SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA. IF THE
STATE BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF
OUR VALUES AND IF WE TRULY
VALUE THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH WE WILL
BEGIN RESTORING FUNDING TO THIS
CRUCIAL PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WHAT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE NINETEEN. MY
ANGER I'M A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA PROPONENT OF THIS
BUDGET REQUEST AND AS THE
CONVENER OF THE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION ROUND TABLE I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE VERY
HAPPY TO BE IN CONVERSATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE
AND EXPAND THIS PROPOSAL. YOU
THINK YOU HAVE. COULD POLLS FOR
FROM A PILLAR HEALTH AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR. JERRY AT
ON THIS WITH THE LOS ANGELES B.
T. CENTER COCONVENER OF THE
STATE SEX AND ROUND TABLE IN
PROUD SUPPORT AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS. THANK YOU. AND EVANS ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT PROPOSAL THANK YOU
MA'AM. RIGHT SPENCER WITH
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN STITCHES
NINE IN SUPPORT YOU. A DALLAS
BLANCHARD FRESNO NEEDLE
EXCHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAKAYLA JONES HIV EDUCATION
PREVENTION PROJECT FROM AN
ACCOUNTING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WESLEY SAID WITH GLIDE
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU. AND ON
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION STRONG SUPPORT. GEN
I HEAR WHAT AT THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROBINSON WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I'M SO LONELY RICK HAS
I'M A JUNIOR I REDWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL IN MY CELL YEAH AND I'M
WITH ACT- FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS-
HAVING MORE ACCESS TO SEXUAL
EDUCATION IS IMPORTANT- BECAUSE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF A TOPIC I IS
GOING TO IMPACT THEIR FUTURES
AND EVEN GET. ACTUAL EDUCATION
AT SCHOOL- IT IS BENEFICIAL TO
HAVE FOR THE COMMUNITY- BECAUSE
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE ACT
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION AND
RESPONSES IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO MAKE IT INCLUDES EVERYONE
CAN MAKE THE DECISIONS THEY
GIVE. YOU I AM KELLY CENTERS
I'M ONE FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS I'M
A FRESHMAN AT REDWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL MY SONYA. SEX ED FOR ALL
AGES IS IMPORTANT FORCE TO
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
ES DE ICING COME ONCE AND STAY
FOREVER- OLDER FOLKS IN HIGH
SCHOOL THE ONLY THING DISCUSS
AND SEX ED WAS ABSTINENCE AND
NOT DIFFERENT WAYS TO PREVENT.
S. T. AS OUR PRACTICE SAFE SEX.
THIS CAN BE THIS CAN OLDER
FOLKS. THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
KID AND HEALTH AND SALAS A SAFE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MICHELLE
RIVERA AT FURMAN GIRLS IN
STRONG SUPPORT GIVE. PLEASE
EISENBERG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. US LIMóN SEAL
SACRAMENTO STATE STUDENT WITH
BACK FOR WINNING GIRLS IN
STRONG SUPPORT YOU. TAMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND JUST WANT TO-
THANK THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THAT COMMUNITY BASED
EDUCATION IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPLEMENT TO SCHOOL BASED
EDUCATION REQUIRED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT OF
WHICH WERE ALSO SPONSOR. SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
AND THE AND THE RESTORATION OF
FINES AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR TENSION TO THIS. SO
BECAUSE DEAL WITH ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE REALLY SEE THIS AS A
COMPLETE WELL ROUNDED BUDGET
PACKAGE. TO HELP REDUCE STD
RATES MOVING THAT PUSH THE FOR.
AND HELPING REDUCE THAT BY
FINDING NAVIGATE YOU KNOW CASE
MANAGEMENT STD TESTING A
PREVENTION AND A COMMUNITY SEX
EDUCATION THANK YOU. WELL AS
WELL AS A MAP OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES A
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. PATSY MONTGOMERY
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD. A
CONSTITUENT. OF CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND I STARTED AS A
HEALTH EDUCATOR IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. DOING I ANY WORK
AND I'VE I'VE WATCHED OVER THE
YEARS THE SUCCESS OF REDUCING
TEEN PREGNANCIES AND ALSO
REDUCING SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS UNFORTUNATELY WE
FALLEN BACK AND S. T. EYES ARE
ON THE RISE. AND IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE THIS
WORKING CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THE WORK OF FINE PEOPLE WHO'VE
TESTIFIED ALREADY TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AT THREE
MENDOCINO COUNTY AIDS VIRAL
HEPATITIS NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU. SHALL GIVEN TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA OUR
APOLOGIES FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET A LETTER IN IN TIME BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING THAT THERE'S NO MORE
PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE. I MAY AND
IF I MAY HAVE WITH PATTY
MONTGOMERY I. DON'T INHERENTLY
WANNA SAY WHICH YEAR I
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL. BUT
I CAN SAY THAT SHE HIRED MY
SISTER- WHILE WE WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL TO DO SOME OF THIS
COMMUNITY EDUCATION. AND IT WAS
VERY INFORMATIVE FOR US TO HAVE
PEERS BE ABLE TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION. AND WAS
APPRECIATED JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE IS NO NEPOTISM NOW SHE'S
HIRED AS A NURSE EDUCATOR
KAISER SO. BUT WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE NINETEEN OPEN
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY. WITH
THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE. PRIOR TO
CONCLUDING WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ANY OF THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS.
WE NEVER COME UP ITEMS NOT ON
THE AGENDA. OKAY OWES- FOR THE
NON DISCUSSION ITEMS WHICH ARE
NEXT WHICH ARE. THE LAST FOUR
SO YES. GO AHEAD YES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND CAT TO
BURKE WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT IS NOT
A CHEN NICE TODAY BUT WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT IT WILL BE AGENDAS
AT A LATER DATE AND I'D LIKE TO
GIVE THE STUDENTS A MATERIALS
TO DISTRIBUTE TO YOU- WE TAKE
ONE TENTH OF 1% OF WHAT WE
SPEND ON HEALTH CARE. IN THE
STATE IN OTHER WORDS TEN
DOLLARS PER CAPITA AND PUT INTO
PREVENTING DISEASE AN INJURY IN
THE FIRST PLACE WE CAN CHANGE
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA THIS TO BE
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA WELLNESS
FUND I CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE PREVENT
FUNDING A GROUP OF OVER TO
INNOVATIONS THAT SUPPORT SUCH A
FUND WITH PREVENTION AS A
PRIORITY AND WITH NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE GOING. FOR START
UP FUNDS TO SHOW HOW ARE MODEL
WILL WORK WITH THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLRS PER YEAR FOR
FIVE YEARS IT'S A BIG ASK BUT
IT'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING REALLY BIG FOR
CALIFORNIA WE ARE TO SUPPORT
OUR PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTER MY NAME STAR LENDS
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
WHICH IS CO SPONSOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WELLNESS FUND BUDGET
REQUEST DOCTOR ANGEL PRESENTED
AN ELOQUENT EXPOSITION OF THE
URGENT NEED FOR THIS MEASURE-
EVEN AS WE SEEK TO ADDRESS THE
PRESSING ISSUES OF THE DAY LIKE
CORONAVIRUS WE CAN NO LONGER
PUNT DOWN THE ROAD YEAR AFTER
YEAR DRESSED IN THOSE NINE OUT
OF TEN DEATHS THAT SHE
DESCRIBED FOR CHRONIC DISEASE-
AND THE RESULTING BURDEN OF
HEALTH INEQUITY IN COST. SO WE
ASK YOU TO PROVIDE MODEST DOWN
PAYMENT SYSTEMATIC COMMUNITY
BASED APPROACH OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF ENDORSED CREATION OF
ASSISTING FUNDING SOURCE OF FOR
PREVENTION AND HEALTH EQUITY
YES THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO JOIN US
IN MAKING THIS PART OF YOUR
VISION FOR THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND WE HOPE
TO RETURN OF. SUBSEQUENT
HEARING ON THE EDGE AND
THINKING. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JULIE AT SAM'S AND I'M
REPRESENTING PREVENTION
INSTITUTE. OF PREVENTION
INSTITUTE HAS WORKED FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS TO ADVANCE
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND WELL BEING
FOR EQUITABLE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND WHAT WE REALLY SEEING
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IS THAT.
THE MULTI SECTOR SORT OF
COLLABORATION- ENERGY AND
SUPPORT IS THERE BUT WHAT WE
LACK IS RESOURCES FOR THAT SORT
OF BACK PHONE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT CAN BRING THE DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS AND PARTNERS
TOGETHER TO REALLY MOVE CHANGE
ON PRESSING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES. SO HERE TO SUPPORT THE
A PROPOSAL FOR ON THIS ONE
THANK YOU. THE SHOCK TO THE
COUNTY EXACTLY ASSOCIATES HOUSE
HERE TO SUPPORT WELLNESS FUND
CONCEPT THAT WAS AT FOR YOU AS
WELL. JUST WHAT IT IS WE HAD A
LOT OF. AROUND DISEASES CHRONIC
DISEASES ALSO ANOTHER AREA
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
ADDRESS AS WELL. HI LISA
EISENBERG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE- I
APPRECIATE THE NUKE THE
COMMITTEES NEW PROCESS FOR
VETTING STAKEHOLDER APPROVALS.
AND WE DIDN'T MAKE THE
DEADLINE- BUT WITH OUR PARTNERS
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT FOR CONSIDERATION A
PROPOSAL- I FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
EXPAND SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA-
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS ARE
PUBLIC HEALTH MULTI FACETED
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
AND WELLNESS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
I'M THEY PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE WAS TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. THEY ADDRESS HEALTH
DISPARITIES THEY REMOVE%
BARRIERS TO ATTENDANCE AND
GRADUATION. THEY PROVIDE SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES AND EDUCATION. THE
SCREEN FOR A SAYS AND ROOM
ADDRESS EXPERIENCES OF TRAUMA.
SO WE ARE IN PRO PROPOSING THIS
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND. THE
PLANNING AND CONSTRUCTION
GRANTS FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED NEW
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- TO
FURTHER THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING. ON MARCH SECOND THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING.